machen der bundestag muss sich in die
lage versetzen die wirkung des mittels
shot down das bei längerer anwendung den
patienten schwer schädigen wird
jederzeit zu überprüfen und
gegebenenfalls die dosis zu verändern
und die mittel auch wieder abzusetzen
psychischer stress durch
freiheitsbeschränkungen existenzängste
sowie arbeitslosigkeit aufgrund von
firmeninsolvenzen die staatliche
stützung zahlung bei einem längeren
shutter und letztlich nicht verhindern
können werden nach einiger zeit zu
verringerter lebensdauer der menschen
führen unterschätzen sie diese effekte
nicht die verhältnisse ist mäßigkeit der
maßnahmen muss gewahrt bleiben
weitere fragen warum wird die jury klage
von 48 milliarden euro nicht aufgelöst
um die exorbitante neuverschuldung des
nachtragshaushalts zu lindern
hierzu sagten sie eben im ausschuss herr
minister dass rücklagen geld liege ja
nicht herum sondern es sei nur eine
kreditermächtigung nun in der tat
genauso wie die neuverschuldung auch
ebenso ist sie ist auch eine
kreditermächtigung nun haben sie eben
zwei davon eine über 156 milliarden eine
über 48 milliarden das ist eine gute
situation aber seriös ist das nicht
warum hat die regierung wieder einmal
den mittelstand fast nicht in die
rettungsmaßnahmen einbezogen also das
rückgrat unserer wirtschaft
warum gibt es im nachtragshaushalt
völlig corona fremde titel wie zum
beispiel mieten im kanzleramt oder
juristisch zweifelhaft
entschädigungszahlen an thomas cook
geschädigte es ist unbedingt diese dinge
hier in corona paket mit verabschieden
zu lassen
generell muss in zeiten einer notlage
geld menschen so viel geld in die hand
genommen wird dann bitte für deutschland
die grünen etwa wollen teile der gelder
erklärtermaßen lieber für europa
verwenden linken wollen bereits einen
nachschlag über 750 milliarden euro
hinaus man hat es ja ebenso natürlich
die ezb und die eu die perfider weise
die gelegenheit corona nun nutzen wollen
um mandats widrig primär euro anleihen
zu kaufen und sogar von deutschland mit
behaftete corona anleihen einzuführen
also illegale eurobonds
fazit ich komme zum schluss selbst in
einer gesundheitlichen notlage sind
solche planungen unseriösen müssen sehr
schnell wieder auf den prüfstand starts
planwirtschaft mit 200 milliarden euro
pro monat kann ohnehin nicht lange
durchgehalten werden
stimmen sie damit bitte unseren anträgen
auf enge befristung und regelmäßige
überprüfungen der derzeitigen harten
maßnahmen zu dann können wir in der
aktuellen notlage auch teilweise
zustimmen sonst werden wir uns enthalten
müssten herzlichen dank
liebe kollegen sie folgt dem nächsten
regel das wort erteilen dürfen sich gar
nicht sitzen
ich möchte noch mal an die kollegen
insbesondere ihrer fraktion appellieren
wir haben den wochenlangen gesprächen
sehr intensiv darüber gewogen und alle
fraktionen waren sehr einvernehmlich ich
bedanke mich auch bei allen fraktionen
dafür dass wir hier die sitzung machen
bei angemessener präsenz und
gleichzeitig bei angemessener wahrung
des abstandsgebot
und deswegen stehen sie bitte nicht
hindert den sitzplätzen im plenum auch
wenn sie da vielleicht sogar den
notwendigen abstand einhalten setzten
sich und wenn im plenarsaal keine plätze
vorhanden sind haben wir oben auf den
tribünen noch plätze im musik platz
nehmen können bitte tun sie uns allen
den gefallen wir haben so eine gute
kooperation in den verfahren gehabt das
war heute auch die letzten zwei stunden
in diesem geist an bringt jetzt bringt
er teile ich das wort kollegen eckhardt
rehberg cdu csu
herr präsident liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen vorab ein herzliches dankeschön
ein dankeschön an die mitarbeiterinnen
und mitarbeiter in den ministerien die
dieses große gesetzespaket was wir heute
gemeinsam verabschieden wollen auf den
weg gebracht haben an die mitarbeiterin
mitarbeiter in den fraktionen in den
abgeordnetenbüros und es wurde der saal
sorry gegenüber den
oppositionsfraktionen bis heute gegen
mitternacht gearbeitet die letzten um
druck kamen zu beginn der
haushaltsausschuss sitzung und deswegen
ein gleichzeitiges dankeschön an das
kooperative verhalten aller fraktionen
bis auf ein herzliches dankeschön
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
ich persönlich mache weder im privaten
noch im öffentlichen bereich gerne
schulden
es war richtig dass gerade die union
über lange zeit dagegen gesträubt haben
dass die schwarze null aufgegeben wird
und wie die schuldenbremse in irgend
einer form umgang wird und die täter der
föderalismusreform die den 115
grundgesetz entworfen haben haben ihn
genau für so eine situation entworfen
wie wir sie heute haben für eine
notsituation die vom staat nicht
verschuldet worden ist deswegen bedanke
ich mich auch hier an dieser stelle bei
der fraktion der linken den grünen und
der fdp beim koalitionspartner
dass wir heute gemeinsam dafür stimmen
werden dass die 115 grundgesetz in kraft
treten kann
das über diesen weg 100 100 milliarden
in der die kreditaufnahme erhöhen können
und dass wir auch die reguläre
schuldenregel in anspruch nehmen mit 0,5
und 30 prozent und dass herr kollege
bürger her mit den 156 milliarden
versetzt uns in die lage im bereich
gesundheit im bereich soziales und dem
bereich wirtschaft das nötige zu tun
was jetzt in einem ersten aufschlag zu
tun ist nicht mehr nicht weniger
wenn sie in die glaskugel gucken können
ich kann das nicht also ich glaube heute
ist ein ganz wichtiger tag für
deutschland für die bundesregierung und
für dieses parlament um dieses paket auf
den weg zu bringen
herr kollege herr kollege rehberg herr
kollege dr
vor der fraktion die linke würde dann
eine zwischenfrage stellen ja gerne
er wird man ganz verdankt dass sie die
zwischenfrage zu lassen es gibt einen
fundamentalen strukturellen punkt der
die unternehmen betrifft zwischen 10 und
250 also 11 249 die kriegen keinen
zuschuss obwohl sie handwerksbetriebe
auch konzertveranstalter also im
kulturbereich hart gebeutelt sind die
werden verwiesen auf die kfw kredite
beziehungsweise damit auf die hausbank
und deren konditionen gedenken sie hier
bei diesem defizit noch nachzubessern
ist das vorgesehen weil das ist absehbar
dass diese möglicherweise den sommer
nicht mehr existenzfähig erreichen
der kollege den wir haben uns
entschieden und das ist glaube ich
richtig so klein und kleinstunternehmen
mit bis zu zehn beschäftigten von seiten
des bundes mit einem zuschuss zu
versehen der steuerbar ist
und ich rate ihnen dringend mal in die
landesprogramme baden württemberg bayern
mecklenburg vorpommern oder in
niedersachsen ich könnte noch weitere
nennen die gerade diesem bereich
zwischen 10 beschäftigten und 50 oder
darüber hinaus und ich finde es genau
richtig in einem föderalen system das
man sich jetzt abgestimmt hat dass wir
die kleinen und kleinsten indes zu zehn
beschäftigten und dann die länder dass
darüber hinaus gehen und dann greifen
die bürgschaftsprogramme da kv dann
haben wir ein 600 milliarden
vom aufgelegte stopp 500 milliarden die
100 milliarden kaffee muss ich ab ziehen
über den wirtschafts
stabilisierungsfonds nicht glaube wenn
man hier sieht von dem selbstständigen
bis hoch zu den großen dax-unternehmen
die kette ist aus meiner sicht sehr
schlüssig und deswegen ist ihre kritik
aus meiner sicht sachlich unbegründet
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen um
deutlich zu machen welchen kraftakt wir
hier stemmen wir haben ein
bruttoinlandsprodukt von rund 3,5
millionen euro
wir werden einen garantierahmen
insgesamt im bundeshaushalt haben von
1,8 billionen davon der erwähnte
wirtschaft stabilisierungsfonds
aber wir warten den garantierahmen im
bundeshaushalt auf über eine billion auf
und genauso richtig ist es glaube ich
auch wenn ich noch mal auf den 115
zurück komme dass dem ein tilgungsplan
beigelegt wird jetzt kann man streiten
sind 20 jahre zu lang aber ich glaube
dass es ein richtiger und angemessener
zeitraum ist ab 20 23 auch hier zu tun
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen lassen
sie mich abschließend noch einmal aus
meiner sicht jedenfalls deutlich machen
wir sind in einer notsituation und wir
haben gerade für diese notsituation den
115 grundgesetz und jetzt kann man auch
in der abfolge der nächsten tage und
wochen hoffen dass die pandemie schnell
zurückgeht dass wir möglichst schnell zu
normalen verhältnis zurückkommen und auf
der anderen seite muss man auch immer im
hinterkopf haben und nicht glaube wir
können dann reagieren wir sind
finanzpolitisch finanziell solide als
bundesrepublik deutschland aufgestellt
um auch eine etwas längere krise
durchzuhalten und ich sagte das noch mal
in aller ruhe in richtung
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen ich
glaube dass auch sie gehalten sind sie
sind gewählte abgeordnete des deutschen
volkes dass man hier nicht
horrorszenarien verbreitet nicht
verschwörungstheorien in die welt setzt
sondern dass man einfach ruhig und
umsichtig und verantwortungsbewusst und
verantwortungsvoll seiner abgeordneten-
tätigkeit nachgeht herzlichen dank
nächster redner kollege christian dürr
fdp herr präsident herzlichen dann
verehrte kolleginnen kollegen das ist ja
in vieler hinsicht heute ein
historischer tag allein die sitzordnung
hier und die umstände die wir zurzeit in
deutschland erleben es ist auch
haushaltspolitisch ein historischer tag
weil wir zum ersten mal in der
geschichte den artikel 119 des
grundgesetzes nutzen um den notfall
mechanismus der schuldenbremse in kraft
zu setzen
allen unkenrufen der letzten monate und
jahre zum trotz diese schuldenbremse
funktioniert auch in krisenzeiten liebe
kollegen kollegen es ist gut dass wir
sie haben und deswegen wird meine
fraktion diesen notfall mechanismus
heute auch zustimmen verehrte kollegin
und kollegen
und gerade weil das so eine besondere
situation ist unter fahre ich in ihre
richtung herr bundesminister scholz
gerade weil das so eine historische
situation ist jetzt auch die
bundesregierung gehalten alles in gang
zu setzen um diese drohende
wirtschaftskrise abzuwenden
der 115 wird vom parlament heute gezogen
auf der anderen seite behalten sie sich
dennoch vor eine rücklage in höhe von 38
millionen euro zurückzuhalten
es wäre jetzt angesichts dieser tatsache
richtig dass auch die bundesregierung in
vorleistung geht und diese rücklage
auflöst auflöst um sie für die
bewältigung der korona krise in
deutschland und der wirtschaftskrise
einzusetzen das wäre ein wichtiges
signal dass sie heute setzen sollten und
genauso wichtig das sage ich in richtung
der koalitionsfraktionen wäre es jetzt
richtig auf politische projekte zu
verzichten
der koalitionsvertrag gilt das ist mir
bewusst aber er muss dieser krise
angepasst werden
teure projekte wie beispielsweise die
grundrente und andere dinge die
sicherlich in ihrem parteiprogramm
stehen sind jetzt nicht mehr an der
tagesordnung sondern jetzt muss diese
krise bewältigt werden den menschen und
unternehmen muss jetzt geholfen werden
deswegen verzichten sie auf solche
teuren projekte aktivieren sie alles zur
bekämpfung dieser krise liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen und zum zweiten
führen wir ein wirtschafts
stabilisierungsfonds 1
auch das ist gut dass sich die
bundesregierung bewegt hat und nicht
deshalb 2000 beschäftigte sondern
bereits ab 249 beschäftigte dass der
wirtschaft zugänglich macht aber so wie
er sparen ist gerade öffentlich gesagt
hat so wie wir eine exit-strategie für
die freiheitsbeschränkung in deutschland
brauchen brauchen wir auch für diesen
mechanismus eine exit strategie
auch hier muss jetzt ein enddatum
vorgelegt werden meine damen und herren
wir wollen keine dauerhaften
staatsbeteiligung an privaten
unternehmen es muss eine notfallmaßnahme
sein wie ein ende haben muss wir wollen
kein um bei der eigentümerstruktur im
deutschen mittelstand meine damen und
herren
auch hier brauchen wir eine exit
strategie und das ist gesagt worden ist
bleibt am ende des tages eine lücke
nämlich alle unternehmen kleinen und
mittleren unternehmen die der wie man so
schön sagt bergbau und der deutschen
wirtschaft sind zwischen elf und 249
beschäftigten dort verweist die
bundesregierung auf förderprogramme der
länder
ich will das in aller klarheit bei
einigkeit über vielen dingen herr scholz
wieder auf telefoniert in den letzten
tagen bei aller einigkeit will ich das
deutlich sagen diese förderlücke bleibt
am ende des tages auch am ende dieses
plenar tages deswegen fordere ich sie
auf sorgen sie schnell für liquidität
beispielsweise über die finanzämter so
wie wir es als freie demokraten ihnen
vorgeschlagen haben damit jetzt
liquidität zu den kleinen und mittleren
unternehmen kommen diese unternehmen
waren in den vergangenen jahren
solidarisch mit dem staat insbesondere
mit dem steuer starb sie haben uns allen
fantastische einnahmen beschert mit
diesem unternehmerinnen unternehmer
dienst persönliche risiko
mit denen muss ich jetzt der steuerstaat
eben auch solidarisch zeigen
deswegen appelliere ich an sie helfen
sie mit liquidität den kleine und
mittlere unternehmen damit am ende des
tages die sagen können wir haben diese
krise erfolgreich bewältigt ich danke
ihnen nächste rednerin ist die kollegin
dr gesine lötzsch die linke
[Applaus]
vielen dank herr präsident meine sehr
geehrten damen und herren die fraktion
die linke hat soeben in der sitzung des
haushaltsausschusses dem hilfspaket
zugestimmt also der aussetzung der
schuldenbremse dem nachtragshaushalt und
der wirtschaftsstabilisierung wir das
sage ich aber in aller deutlichkeit
betrachten das nicht als freibrief für
die bundesregierung wir werden uns dafür
einsetzen dass konstruktionsfehler des
hilfspaketes schnell und wirksam
abgestellt werden ändern kann und bei
allem optimismus ich glaube die meisten
von uns sind sich einig das vorliegende
paket kann nur ein erstes hilfspaket
sein
diese krise kann uns härter treffen als
die finanzkrise 2008 und darum brauchen
wir jetzt rettungsschirme die
krankenschwestern verkäuferinnen und all
diejenigen schützen die unsere
gesellschaft am laufen halten und dafür
ihre gesundheit aufs spiel setzen danke
danke heute schon viel ausgesprochen
jetzt geht es auch um die materielle
anerkennung und ganz deutlich auch die
materielle absicherung denn das merken
ja viele schon das leben wird in der
krise teurer
wir fordern also für diese menschen
jetzt ein risikoaufschlag von 500 euro
im monat
das scheint
das scheint auf den ersten blick viel
geld zu sein doch ein vergleich
ein bundeswehrsoldat zum beispiel der im
ebola gebiet eingesetzt wurde bekamen
ein risikoaufschlag pro tag von 30 bis
110 euro
und ich glaube an diesen vorgaben kann
man sich orientieren meine damen und
herren in frankreich gibt es bereits
zuschläge von einer großen handelskette
für die verkäuferin das ist doch ein
gutes beispiel wie wochen deutschland
gefolgt werden sollte und meine damen
und herren wenn ihr eigenes aus der
finanzkrise gelernt haben sollten dann
es muss während der krise also jetzt
geklärt werden wer die zeche zahlt so
wurde uns damals von der bundesregierung
eine finanztransaktionssteuer
versprochen die immer noch nicht
existiert die rechnung haben die kleinen
leute bezahlt und aufgrund der
finanzkrise wurden krankenhäuser
pflegeheime schulen universitäten und
die öffentliche verwaltung herunter
gespart und die auswirkung dieses
kürzungs kurses bekommt jetzt das
personal in den krankenhäusern zu spüren
und dass es mehr als ungerecht muss
endlich behoben wären meine band hören
und ich sage auch ganz deutlich wir
müssen jetzt die gewinne von krisen
gewinn lang mit einem gesetz deckeln
es kann doch nicht sein dass
krankenschwestern und ärzte ihre
gesundheit aufs spiel setzen und
gleichzeitig die aktionäre der rhön
kliniken ag
um ein beispiel zu denn sich über satte
kursgewinne freuen können nein das ist
das falsche signal jetzt zeit für mehr
gerechtigkeit und ich sage ihnen meine
damen und herren
diese krise ist nur mit solidarität zu
meistern die krise könnte eine
sternstunde der europäischen solidarität
werden einfacher ist es nicht zu haben
beweisen wir diese solidarität vielen
dank sexy kollegin anja hajduk bündnis
90 die grünen herr präsident meine sehr
verehrten damen und herren liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen mit dieser
abstimmung über den nachtragshaushalt
gehen wir in der tat einen sehr sehr
großen und auch sehr entschlossenen
schritt das ist hoffentlich mit
signalwirkung aber das ist auch
notwendig deswegen will ich auch zu
beginn sagen wir grünen werden aus
tiefer überzeugung zu stimmen das ist
eine außergewöhnliche notfallsituation
und deswegen ist es richtig nach den
maßgaben der schuldenbremse diese
besondere zulässige starke verschuldung
jetzt zu ermöglichen um zu zeigen dass
wir in diesem land diese krise auch
bewältigen können und dass wir dazu
seinen beitrag leisten es handelt sich
hier um ein paket von 156 milliarden
wenn wir mal zusammen ziehen was wir
erwarten was wir an weniger
steuereinnahmen haben werden und dass
wir zusätzliche milliarden bereitstellen
wollen
um denjenigen jetzt hilfe zu geben die
auf ihre tätigkeiten verzichten müssen
die dadurch unkosten haben und die
dadurch natürlich auch sorgen haben und
wir brauchen dieses geld auch um unser
gesundheitssystem fit zu machen und das
möglichst leistungsfähig zu halten
wir wissen aber auch dass das
wahrscheinlich nicht das letzte mal sein
wird dass wir hier über maßnahmen
diskutieren
der finanzminister hat in seinem
nachtragshaushalt
zugrunde gelegt so ungefähr einen
wirtschaftlichen einbruch wie wir ihnen
vor etwas mehr als zehn jahren erlebt
haben das waren damals minus fünf
prozent wenn man jetzt weiß manche reden
aber davon das kann vielleicht auch das
doppelte sein
dann wissen wir dass auch noch
zusätzliche maßnahmen notwendig sind und
deswegen möchten wir grüne sehr
dringlich anmahnen wir brauchen dann
auch noch kraft und luft für eine
investitionsoffensive wenn die krise
überstanden ist und sie kann auch noch
viel größer werden das müssen wir heute
schon im blick behalten und deswegen
müssen die tilgungsverpflichtungen im
zweifel auch angepasst werden wir
brauchen sie
wir wollen sie auch festlegen aber wir
müssen das im auge behalten was wir dann
leisten können wir brauchen diese
programme für kleinstunternehmer wir
haben das diskutiert wir wollen einen
großen wirtschafts stabilisierungsfonds
von mehreren hundert milliarden
ermöglichen
aber ich will von grüner seite auch ganz
deutlich anmahnen
wir brauchen auch solidarität mit blick
auf europa und das sind uns grünen
bisher einfach nur zu wenig warme worte
oder zu nur warme worte
statt klarer ansagen sie können herr
scholz mit veranlassen dass die staats
und regierungschefs morgen
vorsorgliche kreditlinien des esm für
alle europäischen länder zugänglich
machen
machen sie das sorgen sie dafür der
druck in italien und spanien ist jetzt
da und wir würden auch als grüne die
idee richtig finden unsere kreditanstalt
für wiederaufbau denen die möglichkeit
zu geben die entsprechende förderbank in
italien zu unterstützen und nicht zu
vergessen
wir wissen doch alle dass das
gesundheitssystem der ernsten länder
schon heute ein signal braucht dass wir
auch in der internationalen gemeinschaft
bereit stehen werden auch mit milliarden
denen zu helfen durch die krise zu
kommen
diese beiden punkte haben wir im
haushaltsausschuss angemahnt das heißt
auch solidarität und deswegen müssen wir
uns sicherlich demnächst hier wieder
versammeln und weitere maßnahmen
beschließen auch wenn wir und das geben
wir gerne zu das entschlossene handeln
der regierung sehr gerne konstruktiv
begleitet haben schön das nächste reden
ist der kollege joachim frey wird
ioc-präsident meine sehr geehrten damen
und herren das ist heute in der tat er
schon oft angesprochen worden wir sind
in einer sondersituation und wir
verabschieden heute in notfallmaßnahmen
und soforthilfen in einem umfang der
bisher noch nie da gewesen ist und zwar
für unternehmer und für arbeitnehmer in
allen wirtschaftsbereichen gleichermaßen
und die demission ist in der tat
gigantisch historisch einmalig aggregat
hat es angesprochen für einem
bruttosozialprodukt von knapp 3,5
millionen also 3500 milliarden im jahr
2019 werden jetzt mit diesem schirmen
gesamtpaket 1400 milliarden zur
verfügung gestellt wenn es letztlich den
auch darauf ankommen würde
das heißt ungefähr 40 prozent unseres
sozialproduktes 40 prozent unseres
sozialproduktes und wo man die dimension
auch noch einmal darzustellen wir haben
weil wir gut gewirtschaftet haben weil
unser unternehmen wettbewerbsfähig waren
und gut steuern bezahlt
weil wir im haushalt in den letzten
jahren konsolidiert haben haben wir es
geschafft unsere verschuldung unter 60
prozent abzusenken und deshalb können
wir uns solche 40 prozent in dieser
ausnahmesituation jetzt eher leisten als
andere länder in europa wie man nach
frankreich schauen die haben 100
verschuldung ihres bips in italien sogar
130 prozent
es ist die dimension vor denen wir
stehen in europa vor der wir auch hier
in deutschland stehen und ich will noch
einmal deutlich machen
es geht nicht darum alle gleich zu
behandeln
das ist nicht das ziel dieser programme
und initiativen der solo selbstständige
freiberufler in der werbe wirtschaft
muss anders behandelt werden wie der
handwerker und der muss wiederum anders
behandelt werden als der
mittelständische maschinenbauer mit 200
beschäftigen und der muss wiederum
anders behandelt werden als die
lufthansa oder andere unternehmen und
deshalb haben wir nicht alle waren
leisten scheren so wir haben
unterschiedliche herangehensweisen
es gibt zunächst und es gilt für alle
gestern auch beschlossen und das soll
nach draußen auch allen tagen die
sozialversicherungsbeiträge sind für
märz diesen jahres und verabredet dieses
jahres nicht zu bezahlen das schafft
liquidität und hält liquidität
es ist unsere oberste priorität
liquidität in unternehmen zu halten
liquidität zu sichern und liquidität wo
es notwendiges zuzuführen
deshalb wird auch gestundet im bereich
von steuervorauszahlungen und deshalb
bekommen jetzt mit den soforthilfen solo
selbstständige unternehmen bis fünf
mitarbeitern und unternehmen bis zehn
mitarbeitern vom bund einmalzahlung
direkthilfen auf drei monaten
unbürokratisch ausbezahlt elektronisch
können sie beantragt worden waren
nachträglich geprüft ohne entsprechende
voraussetzungen diese programme warten
die angesprochenen enge abstimmungen
auch vom bund und ländern ergänzt so
dass beispielsweise dann direkt zahlen
ortes 50 oder 100 arbeitnehmern erfolgen
und intermeat bis zu den 250
mitarbeitern gibt es die
liquiditätsprogramme die auch vor zehn
tagen entsprechend unbegrenzt zur
verfügung gestellt wurden dort hat der
bund seine garantien und
gewährleistungen auf 822 milliarden
erhöht bis 50 millionen euro 90 prozent
abdeckung durch den bund diese ps müssen
wir auf die piste bringen und da gibt es
wenn uns das gelingt auch keine lücke
und dann für größere unternehmen vor die
strukturell bedeutend sind die von der
insolvenz bedroht sind oder auch wenn es
um nationale interesse gehen haben wir
als ultima ratio auch allen vor der dann
in der lage ist mit 100 milliarden euro
sicht direkt zu beteiligen mit anteilen
mit aktien auch mit stillen
beteiligungen darüber hinaus es ist aber
die ultima ratio und nicht die regel das
will ich auch in aller deutlichkeit
sagen und mit dem programm versuchen wir
differenziert heranzugehen
wir wollen aber nicht die soziale
marktwirtschaft abschaffen oder sie
außer kraft setzen ist eine
notfallsituation um die kümmern wir uns
jetzt und dann können wir uns wenn es
vorbei ist oder wer licht am ende des
tunnels sehen natürlich auch um eine
exit strategie
aber jetzt geht es darum sofort zu
helfen denen die das bedürftig sind ich
wünsche ihnen und uns allen gottes segen
und beste gesundheit und lassen sie uns
gemeinsam diesen weg so weiter gehen
dabei dann selber hoffen die ich auch
wieder bald ende licht am ende des
tunnels
nächste reden ist der kollegin katrin
spd sehr geehrter herr präsident liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen was wir hier
und heute beschließen das sind nicht nur
abstrakte worte und zahlen für viele
menschen in diesem land geht es in
dieser corona krise nicht nur um ihre
gesundheit sondern auch um ihr
wirtschaftliches überleben und zwar
völlig ohne eigenes verschulden letzte
woche komme ich in marburg zu meinem
friseur peter aber normalerweise ist der
laden voll
am samstag waren es nur noch sechs leute
jetzt kommt niemand mehr
wie viele läden ist sein geschäft zu
ziemlich verzweifelt haben er und seine
frau von ihrer angst erzählt sie sorgen
sich um ihre gesundheit und fast genauso
existenzielles für sie dass sie nicht
wissen wovon sie ihre rechnungen künftig
zahlen sollen und genauso geht es gerade
sehr sehr vielen vom selbständigen
taxifahrer über die angestellten im
buchladen die chefin eines
mittelständigen autozulieferers bis hin
zu großunternehmen nach einer
ifo-umfrage spüren jetzt bereits 56
prozent der deutschen unternehmen
negative auswirkungen durch die korona
krise wie sich die umsätze in den
unterschiedlichen branche mittel und
langfristig entwickeln zum beispiel in
der touristik der gastronomie und im
verkehr
das können wir doch noch gar nicht
absehen alleine luftfahrtsektor
beziffert seine aktuell absehbaren
verluste weltweit auf einen
dreistelligen milliardenbetrag
es ist klar deutschlands wirtschaft wird
2020 schrumpfen
dies wird zu wohlstandsverlusten und
sinkenden steuereinnahmen führen das ist
die größte ökonomische krise seit 70
jahren und diese krise bekommen wir nur
gemeinsam in den griff
unsere beschlüsse zum nachtragshaushalt
stabilisieren einkommen arbeitsplätze
und die wirtschaft als ganzes wir helfen
den kleinen unternehmen und den
mittelstand unser ziel ist dass wir
möglichst viele dieser unter
solo selbstständigen durch die krise
gekommen unser maßnahmenpaket bringt den
kleinstunternehmen zusammen mit dem
programm der ländern erst einmal luft
zum atmen
mit dem kfw programm und auch dem
wirtschaftsstabilisierung fonds helfen
wir den mittelstand und auch den start
ups mit liquidität oder auch gegen
feindliche übernahmen
selbstverständlich sind auch die mittel
des staates nicht unendlich und klar wir
werden nicht jeden wunsch erfüllen nicht
alles zu 100 prozent ausgleichen können
aber wir werden unseren staat die
wirtschaft und die existenzgrundlage
unserer bürgerinnen und bürger möglich
stabilisieren
erfreulicher ehrlicherweise stehen wir
noch am anfang niemand weiß was noch auf
uns zukommt insbesondere wie lange diese
krise dauert im zweifel werden wir auch
mit gesetzen und geld hier noch mal
nachsteuern müssen aber es ist auch ganz
klar mit dem was wir hier heute auf den
weg bringen gehen wir einen
entscheidenden schritt wir stützen das
rückgrat dieses staates die
arbeitsplätze die wirtschaft und
letztlich die existenz der menschen
dieses landes
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen mit
diesem gesetzespaket tun wir das was wir
als parlament jetzt tun können und ich
wünsche mir dass sie alle gesund bleiben
und möglichst wieder da draußen
dankeschön
voraussichtlich letzter redner in dieser
debatte ist der kollege doch bei einer
bande cdu/csu liebe kollegin kollegen
eine ermahnung nicht hinter den
sitzplätzen stehen zu bleiben
bezieht sich nicht nur auf eine fraktion
sondern auf alle
also jetzt hat das wort herr kollege
reinhard brandl
vielen dank herr präsident meine sehr
verehrten kolleginnen und kollegen die
korona pandemie stellt unser land vor
eine schwere prüfung und wir werden
diese prüfung nur bestehen wenn wirklich
alle jeder einzelne an seinem fleck als
einen beitrag dazu leistet und viele tun
das bereits und die schönen momente für
mich in diesen tagen sind wenn ich im
alltag erleben buffet einsicht wie viel
vernunft und wie solidarität in unserer
gesellschaft vorhanden ist und dass
meine verehrten kolleginnen und kollegen
stimmt mich hoffnungsvoll für die
nächsten tage haben ich möchte mich bei
allen vernünftigen in unserem land ganz
herzlich bedanken
die situation ist ernst und wir werden
viel geduld brauchen bis wir wieder zu
einem normalen leben zurückfinden können
und wir werden viel geld brauchen damit
das loch in das wir gerade fallen nicht
zu tiefe damit unser gesundheitssystem
jeden einzelnen gut behandeln kann und
damit wir arbeitsplätze und unternehmen
in unserem land sichern der bunder zeit
2013 keine neuen schulden mehr gemacht
wir haben in der guten zeit solide
gewirtschaftet damit wir in einer
notsituation handeln können und das ist
jetzt wir werden jetzt gleich nach
meiner rede nach außen schreiten und
abstimmen und 156 milliarden euro an
krediten aufnehmen aber nicht alle auf
herr kollege bitte wir werden uns
selbstverständlich an die regeln halten
die uns der präsident mit auferlegt hat
aber herr präsident wir müssen es tun
weil wir brauchen das geld wir brauchen
das geld um unsere steuerausfälle
auszugleichen
wir brauchen das geld um soforthilfen
für kleine und mittlere unternehmen
auszuzahlen
und wir brauchen das geld um unsere
kapazitäten im gesundheitssystem und in
der wissenschaft auf die krise
einzustellen
wir werden einen
wirtschaftsstabilisierung einrichten mit
dem es den mit dem es dem staat sogar
ermöglicht wird sich an unternehmen
direkt zu beteiligen um sie vor einem
ausverkauf ins ausland zu schützen
wir werden den garantierahmen der kfw
und meine damen und herren das sind
maßnahmen die sich bereits schon einmal
bewährt haben nämlich in der
wirtschafts- und finanzkrise 2008/2009
und wir sind aus dieser wirtschafts und
finanzkrise damals stärker
herausgegangen als wir hineingegangen
sind
und das wollen wir dieses mal aber
dieses mal ist die prüfung härter weil
es betrifft nicht nur einzelne
unternehmen und nicht nur banken sondern
es betrifft jeden einzelnen von uns
wir brauchen die durch wir brauchen geld
aber das alleine wird nicht reichen
wir werden auch glück brauchen dass es
zb gelingt einen impfstoff zu entwickeln
und meine damen und herren wir werden
auch gottes segen brauchen damit die
menschen in dieser schweren zeit auch
die notwendige kraft und zuversicht
finden in diesem sinne bleiben sie
gesund und herzlichen dank für ihre
aufmerksamkeit
damit schließt sich die aussprache
wir kommen tagesordnungspunkt 4 a zur
abstimmung über die beschlussempfehlung
des haushaltsausschusses zu dem antrag
der fraktion der cdu/csu und spd mit dem
titel beschluss des bundestages gemäß
artikel 115 absatz weisheit 6 und 7 des
gesetzes folgte der ausschuss empfiehlt
seiner beschlussempfehlung auf der
drucksache 18 131 den antrag der
fraktionen der cdu/csu und spd auf der
friesacher aktien 108 anzunehmen
nach artikel 115 absatz 6 des
grundgesetzes ist zur annahme der
business empfehlung die mehrheit der
mitglieder des hauses das sind
mindestens 325 stimmen erforderlich
in abstimmung erfolgt namentlich für die
namentliche abstimmung haben wir
verabredet dass die orgel nicht im saal
sondern in der west lobby aufgestellt
werden
wegen des notwendigen sicherheitsabstand
sind die sechs sondern in einem größeren
abstand zueinander aufgestellt beachten
sie wie die bodenmarkierungen pult
bildung ist unbedingt zu vermeiden
sie haben übrigens jetzt eine stunde
zeit währenddessen gehen die beratungen
weiter ihre stimme abzugeben sie
brauchen jetzt also nicht alle auf
einmal raus deshalb ich schon während
der rede des kollegen brandl noch einmal
in erinnerung gemacht achten sie bitte
auch auf die wahrung der distanz zu den
schriftführerin und zu führen oder den
plätzen blender assistenz sind wie
gesagt 60 minuten lang haben sie zeit
und wenn erst die mit dem
anfangsbuchstaben der ersten hälfte des
alphabets ein bisschen vorher gehen und
die anderen später geht es auch noch
leichter ich bin die die schriftführerin
und schriftführer die vorgesehenen
plätze einzunehmen
da habe ich in zeichen bekommen ob das
auch der fall ist das scheint der fall
zu sein
dann bitte ich also wie gesagt die
kollegen kollegen der nachname mit den
buchstaben a bis k begehen zur
abstimmung aber auch die nicht alle auf
einmal und die anderen dann in etwa
einer halben stunde das ergebnis der das
ende der abstimmung wird rechtzeitig
bekannt gegeben und die abstimmungen
werden
naja 14.15 uhr 56 geschlossen ich hoffe
dir die namentliche abstimmung über die
beschlussempfehlung und komme jetzt
zugleich denn wir beraten einfach weiter
zur abstimmung über den
entschließungsantrag der fraktionen der
afc auf der drucksache 15 159 wer stimmt
für diesen entschließungsantrag
wer stimmt dagegen wer hält sich dann
ist dieser entschließungsantrag gegen
die stimmen der asc mit den stimmen des
übrigen hauses abgelehnt dann kommen wir
zur tagesordnung vom 4b abstimmung über
den von der bundesregierung
eingebrachten gesetzentwurf über die
feststellung eines nachtrags zum bundes
haushaltsplan für das jahr 2020
die stellungnahme des bundesrats gemäß
artikel 110 absatz 3 des grundgesetzes
liegt auf der drucksache 18 125 vor der
haushaltsausschuss empfiehlt in seiner
beschlussempfehlung auf der drucksache
18 132 den gesetzentwurf der
bundesregierung auf den drucksachen 18
118 125 in der ausschuss fassung
anzunehmen ich biete diejenigen die dem
gesetzentwurf in der ausschuss fassung
zustimmen wollen um das anzeichen
hier stimmt dagegen enthält sich dann
ist der gesetzentwurf in zweiter
beratung bei enthaltung der afd mit den
stimmen des übrigen hauses angenommen
tritt die beratung und schlussabstimmung
ich bitte diejenigen dem gesetzentwurf
zustimmen wollen sich zu erheben
daran gesehen wäre stimmt dagegen daran
wie sehr wir enthält sich daran gesehen
dann ist der gesetzentwurf bei
enthaltung der afg mit den stimmen des
übrigen hauses angenommen jetzt kommen
wir zur abstimmung über die
entschließungsanträge zunächst
entschließungsantrag der fraktionen der
fdp auf der drucksache 18 152 wer stimmt
für diesen entschließungsantrag der fdp
fdp stehe wer stimmte gegen die
koalition und die linke wer enthält sich
bündnis 90 die grünen der
entschließungsantrag ist mit den
festgestellten mehrheiten abgelehnt
dann kommt der entschließungsantrag der
fraktionen die linke auf der drucksache
18 153 wer stimmt für diesen
entschließungsantrag
wer stimmt dagegen wer enthält sich dann
ist dieser entschließungsantrag gegen
die stimmen der fraktion die linke bei
enthaltung von bündnis 90 die grünen mit
den stimmen des übrigen hauses abgelehnt
jetzt kommen wir zur pro
tagesordnungspunkt 4 c abstimmung über
den von den fraktionen der cdu/csu und
spd eingebrachten gesetzentwurf zur
errichtung eines wirtschafts
stabilisierungsfonds der
haushaltsausschuss empfiehlt die zahl
der beschluss im verlauf der drucksache
1833 den gesetzentwurf der fraktionen
der cdu/csu und spd auf der drucksache
18 109 in der ausschuss fassung
anzunehmen ich bin die diejenigen die
bis jetzt entwurf der ausschuss fassung
zustimmen wollen um das anzeigen
das stimmt dagegen enthält sich da nicht
der gesetzentwurf in zweiter beratung
bei enthaltung der asc mit den stimmen
des übrigen hauses angenommen dritte
beratung schlussabstimmung ich bin
diejenige gesetzentwurf zustimmen wollen
sich zu erheben sagen wie sehr das
stimmt dagegen da eigentlich sehr wer
enthält sich daran gesehen ist der
gesetzentwurf in dritter lesung medizin
mehrheitsverhältnissen angenommen
damit kommen wir zum abstimmung denise
ließ uns antrag der fraktion der fdp auf
der drucksache 18.000 154 wer stimmt zu
diesen entschließungsantrag
wer ist ihm dagegen wäre enthält sich
dadurch dieser entschließungsantrag
gegen die stimmen der fdp bei enthaltung
der afg und bündnis wollen die grünen
mit den stimmen des übrigen hauses
abgelehnt tagesordnungspunkt 4 d
beratung der unterrichtung durch die
bundesregierung über eckpunkte zur
corona soforthilfe für
kleinstunternehmen und solo
selbstständige ich gehe davon aus dass
sie die unterrichtung auf der drucksache
18.100 hin zur kenntnis genommen haben
damit ist die kenntnisnahme festgestellt
und wir kommen zur abstimmung über den
entschließungsantrag der fraktionen die
linke auf der drucksache 18 124 wäre
stimmt für diesen entschließungsantrag
bestimmt dagegen enthält sich seine
spieler entschließungsantrag gegen die
stimmen der linke bei enthaltung von
bündnis 90 die grünen mit den stimmen
des übrigen hauses abgelehnt und der
tagesordnungspunkt 4 ist die abstimmung
über den antrag der fraktion der asd auf
der drucksache 18.000 116 mit dem titel
antrag auf uneingeschränkte und
sofortige abschaffung des
solidaritätszuschlags
aufgrund der korona pandemie wäre es dem
für diesen antrag
wer stimmt dagegen wäre enthält sich
dann ist der antrag gegen die stimmen
der afd
mit den stimmen des übrigen hauses
abgelehnt tagesordnungspunkt 4 f ab 10
uhr in anderen der fraktionen der
anstifter drucksache 8 10115 mit dem
titel anreize für mehr erntehelfer in
der landwirtschaft wäre der korona krise
wer stimmt für diesen antrag
das stimmt dagegen wäre enthält sich
dann ist der antrag gegen die stimme der
stehen mit den stimmen des übrigen
hauses abgelehnt tagesordnungspunkt 4g
abstimmung über den anderer fraktionen
der drucksache aktien 1120 mit dem titel
wirtschaftliche maßnahmen gegen die
auswirkungen der carola krise mehr
stimmt für diesen antrag
das stimmt dagegen
während hält sich dann ist auch dieser
antrag gegen die stimmen der afg mit den
stimmen des übrigen hauses abgelehnt und
wir kommen zum tagesordnungspunkt 4 ha
das ist der antrag der fraktion der af
der drucksache 18.100 21 mit dem titel
fristen verlängerung aufgrund der korona
pandemie für alle zu § 93 der
geschäftsführung des deutschen
bundestags überwiesenen eu dokumenten
über den antrag abgestimmt für den
antrag
das stimmt dagegen enthält sich und ich
sage dieser anderer gegen die stimme der
asd mit den stimmen des übrigen hauses
abgelehnt und zum tagesordnungspunkt 4
stimmen wir ab über den antrag der
fraktionen der afg der drucksache 18.000
119 mit dem titel lebensnotwendige
energieversorgung sicher und
kosteneffizient ermöglichen
klimaschutzmaßnahmen und förderung
unvorhersehbar schwankender
energiequellen beenden wer stimmt für
diesen antrag
wer sind dagegen wäre enthält sich dann
ist auch dieser anderer gegen die
stimmen der afc mit den stimmen des
übrigen hauses abgelehnt damit häufig
auf den tagesordnungspunkt fünf zweite
und dritte beratung des von den
fraktionen der cdu/csu und spd
eingebrachten gesetzentwurfs zur
abmilderung der folgen der kogit 19
pandemie im zivil insolvenz und
strafverfahrensrecht es liegen dazu
mehrere änderungsanträge und
entschließungsanträge vor
es ist eine für die aussprache eine
dauer von 30 minuten beschlossen
wenn der eine oder andere jetzt dann
zwischendurch auch mal zur abstimmung
geht nicht dass er am ende an die nicht
zur abstimmung war würde ich jetzt die
aussprache eröffnen und das wort hat die
bundesminister justizministerin frau
christine lambrecht
herr präsident meine sehr geehrten damen
und herren liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen die pandemie kubik 19 stellt
uns alle als bürgerinnen und bürger als
abgeordnete aber auch uns
regierungsmitglieder vor große vor sehr
große herausforderung und der
vizekanzler scholz hat heute morgen zu
recht gesagt für den umgang mit einer
solchen krise mit einer solchen
herausforderungen gibt es keine
blaupause aber wir alle haben dennoch
unter hochdruck uns daran gemacht die
herausforderung anzunehmen und in der
bundesregierung in den ministerien
gesetze erarbeitet die die notwendigen
hilfen und die notwendigen
entscheidungen auch enthalten
im gesundheitswesen damit diejenigen die
dafür sorgen dass menschen gesund
bleiben können alle voraussetzungen auch
haben in bezug auf wirtschaftliche
hilfen damit auswirkungen beispielsweise
bei einnahmeausfällen durch kurzarbeit
oder wenn aufträge wegbrechen abgefedert
werden können aber auch in meinem
zuständigkeitsbereich gibt es
entscheidungen die dringend getroffen
werden müssen
dazu gehören beispielsweise die
aussetzung von insolvenzanträgen das
unternehmen nicht in die insolvenz jetzt
getrieben werden müssen weil aufträge
wegbrechen aber auf der anderen seite
auch dann wenn sie diese anträge nicht
gestellt hätten in schwierigkeiten
nämlich indem insolvenzverschleppung
gekommen wären
und deswegen war es wichtig und richtig
diese fristen jetzt auszusetzen bis in
den september
wir haben aber auch entschieden dass
beispielsweise aufgrund der schwierigen
anwesenheits möglichkeit in vielen
gremien jetzt zum beispiel eine digitale
hauptversammlung in aktiengesellschaften
möglich ist auch dass ein wichtiger
punkt und natürlich auch das im
strafprozess in der strafe in der
hauptverhandlung dass diese unterbrochen
werden kann länger als bisher möglich
damit eben wird wie wichtige prozesse
die auch viele an vorbereitungen schon
mit sich gebracht haben nicht noch mal
von vorne aufgerollt werden müssen und
deswegen haben
die fristen die friste auffrisst
ausgedehnt auf drei monate und zehn tage
meine damen und herren das sind alles
wichtige entscheidungen aber ich möchte
wenn ich ehrlich bin auf den kernpunkte
eines gesetzes den ich vorgelegt habe
kommen und er bezieht sich nämlich auf
das mietrecht ganz viele menschen in
diesem land haben momentan mit
einnahmeausfällen müssen damit umgehen
beispielsweise weil die kurzarbeit jetzt
haben das heißt sie bekommen nur noch 60
prozent oder in brechen die aufträge weg
weil sie ihr restaurant nicht mehr
aufrecht erhalten können oder weil
niemand mehr etwas in auftrag gibt und
das ist eine große sorge und deswegen
ist es richtig dass wir heute viele
hilfen aufgelegt haben dazu gehört dass
es grundsicherung vereinfacht gibt dazu
gehört aber auch dass es direkte hilfen
gibt dazu gehört dass kinderzuschlag
einfache gewährt werden kann
aber alles das braucht eine gewisse zeit
bis es eben entschieden und dann das
geld auch bei den bürgerinnen und
bürgern ist und bis es soweit ist haben
viele menschen angst davor dass sie
aufgrund weniger einnahmen ihre miete
nicht mehr bezahlen können und dann
womöglich gekündigt und auf die straße
gesetzt werden und das in der heutigen
zeit wo alles unsicher ist wo alles im
fluss ist wo große ängste zusammenkommen
und deswegen war es mir wichtig dass wir
aufzeigen dass wir die
kündigungsmöglichkeit wegen
zahlungsverzug in der jetzigen zeit
aussetzen und zwar bis zum 30 juni
diesen jahres meine damen und herren
damit klar ist diese sorge muss nicht
noch zu vielen anderen sorgen in der
jetzigen zeit hinzu kommt wenn es zu
hause die wohnung ist doch momentan der
rückzugsort an dem sie meistens sich
aufhalten ja aufhalten müssen und damit
dieser sicher ist deswegen glaube ich
war das eine sehr wichtige entscheidung
es geht aber auch um viele kleinst
gewerbetreibenden denn die sind auch
etwas das auch sie keine angst haben
müssen weil sie jetzt keine aufträge
bekommen und die einnahmen wegbrechen
dass ihnen gekündigt werden
es geht wie gesagt um das
kündigungsrecht dass das ausgesetzt ist
für drei monate
auch das gibt sicher jetzt bekomme ich
natürlich in dem zusammenhang fehler
anschreiben ja was ist denn mit den
vermietern
die haben doch auch schwierigkeiten ja
und aus dem grund haben wir in diesem
gesetz auch das berücksichtigt nämlich
immer dann wenn vermieter diese objekte
darlehens finanziert haben
dann muss selbstverständlich auch die
möglichkeit sein wenn durch corona
bedingt ausfälle gegeben sind dass diese
darlehen ausgesetzt werden können das
ist die andere seite der medaille meine
damen und herren
deswegen ist es ein gerechter ausgleich
den der mit diesem gesetz heute hier
beschließen
und als letztes darf ich noch darauf
hinweisen dass wir ein moratorium für
dauerschuldverhältnis heute beschließen
furchtbares wort aber eine ganz wichtige
sache
es geht nämlich darum dass ihnen durch
zahlungsverzug wenn sie das jetzt nicht
mehr leisten können nicht der strom
abgestellt wird oder das wasser oder das
gas man will sich das gar nicht
vorstellen was das für eine konsequenz
hätte ich bin den versorgungsunternehmen
dankbar dass sie erklärt haben sie
werden es dazu sowieso nicht kommen
lassen
aber das ist gut aber durch dieses
gesetz haben die schuldner daneben auch
die entsprechende rechtssicherheit meine
damen und herren und das ist wichtig in
gerade so einer zeit der unsicherheit
[Applaus]
die verfassungsfrage darunter darf dafür
werben wir haben sehr enge redezeiten
verabredet und ich wäre ihnen dankbar
wenn sie sich auch daran halten also ein
verfassungsbruch an dieser stelle als
justizministerin und denkbar
deswegen möchte ich nur noch ganz kurz
danke an alle die einstimmig diesem
gesetzentwurf im ausschuss zugestimmt
haben das zeigt dass es eine breite
einen breiten konsens gibt die sorgen
und nöte der menschen in diesem land in
dieser schwierigen situation ernst zu
nehmen und ich möchte auch noch mal den
dank an die mittleren mitarbeiterinnen
und mitarbeitern des hauses auch an
dieser stelle mal aussprechen denn da
wurde echt unter hochdruck enormes
geleistet vielen dank und ich danke
ihnen für ihre aufmerksamkeit
jens meyer als der nächste redner
[Applaus]
sehr geehrter herr präsident meine damen
und herren ich habe jetzt zwei minuten
redezeit kann nicht viel sagen aber in
notzeiten hat die regierung das wort an
ihr ist es das land durch die nothin
durchzuführen
eine verantwortungsvoll handelnde
opposition der das eigene volk das
vaterland am herzen liegt begleitet den
weg der regierung in dieser zeit
konstruktiv mit opposition um der
opposition willen verbietet sich die afg
fraktion ist sich dieser verantwortung
bewusst und hat deshalb mehrere
änderungsanträge und ein
entschließungsantrag eingebracht
im bereich des wohn und gewerberaum
mietrechts geht es vor allen dingen
darum den vermieter nicht hinten runter
fallen zu lassen
deshalb soll nach unseren vorstellungen
änderungsantrag der mieter im hinblick
auf den erweiterten kündigungsschutz
bereits bei nichtleistung der biete
glaubhaft machen dass seine
zahlungsunfähigkeit auf die krise
zurückzuführen ist um missbrauch zu
verhindern und den vermieter frühzeitig
zu informieren
darüber hinaus wollen wir über den
schließungs antrag erreichen dass den
vermieter nach der krise unter den
vermieter nach der krise eine
perspektive eröffnet wird möglichst
schnell die offenen beträge zu erhalten
denn die mieten werden nicht erlassen
das muss man vielleicht auch noch mal
deutlich betonen
im hinblick auf die bei
darlehensverträgen vorgesehenen
befristeten leistungsverweigerung
rechten haben wir einen änderungsantrag
eingebracht der vorsieht nicht nur
verbraucher und kleinstunternehmer
sondern auch kleinere und mittlere
unternehmen in den anwendungsbereich
einzubeziehen weil auch diese
unternehmen schutzwürdig sind
bitte greifen sie unsere
änderungsanträge auf und stimmen sie ihm
zu vielen dank nächster redner der
kollege john jack look der jan marco
luczak cdu/csu präsident meine sehr
verehrten damen und herren liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen wir sind uns
alle eigentlich die korona pandemie das
ist sicher die größte herausforderung
die unser land seit vielen vielen
jahrzehnten zu bewältigen hat und dass
davon sind alle gesellschaftlichen
bereiche betroffen der
gesundheitsbereich die einschränkung der
persönlichen freiheit betriebe müssen
schließen aufträge brechen weg und
menschen verlieren ihren job und wir
werden sicher das muss man offen und
ehrlich sagen nicht alles abfedern davon
können wir können den menschen nicht
versprechen dass niemand am ende
wirtschaftlichen schaden nimmt aber und
deswegen läuft ja gerade diese absolut
wir stemmen uns mit allem was wir haben
dagegen wir wollen die wirtschaftlichen
folgen abmildern
deswegen machen wir gerade ein
dreistelliges milliarden
rettungsprogramm
um das zu erwirken aber auch die
rechtspolitik muss hier ihren beitrag
dazu leisten und deswegen werden wir an
verschiedenen gesetzen veränderungen
vornehmen um dieses rettungspaket diese
hilfsmaßnahmen zu flankieren denn unser
ziel ist ganz klar
niemand soll wegen der korona krise
seine wirtschaftliche existenz verlieren
und deswegen machen wir ein
umfangreiches gesetzespaket da geht es
um den preis des insolvenzrechtes um das
gesellschaftsrecht und das
strafprozessrecht am ende geht es darum
die handlungsfähigkeit zu erhalten und
da gibt es ganz verschiedene maßnahmen
die wir dort machen ich will mich hier
auf dem bereich des zivilrechts
konzentrieren denn das ist das was die
menschen ganz unmittelbar betrifft wir
haben viele menschen die in kurzarbeit
gehen müssen die möglicherweise ihren
job jetzt infolge der krise verlieren wo
betriebe zu machen und das ist unser
ziel mit diesem gesetzespaket diese
wirtschaftlichen folgen von corona
abzumildern und deswegen wollen wir ein
doppeltes signal mit diesem gesetz aus
senden
wir wollen den menschen ihre
existenziellen ängste neben sorgen neben
dass die insbesondere ihre wohnung
verlieren könnten dass ihre
betriebsstätte nicht mehr
aufrechterhalten werden kann
das wollen wir ihnen mit diesem gesetz
nehmen und gleichzeitig wollen wir auch
das signal aussenden dass wir den
wirtschaftskreislauf dass wir den am
laufen halten dass wir auch ein
vertrauen in den fortbestand von
verträgen halten und wir tun in dem zu
sagen das was notwendig ist aber wir
reduzieren die einblicke und das muss
man auch deutlich sagen es ist ein
tiefer massiver eingriff in bestehende
verträge das ordnungsrechtlich alles
andere als trivial und deswegen tun wir
das was notwendig ist aber reduzieren
die eingriffe auf das zwingend
notwendige maß und deswegen bei uns als
union auch sehr sehr wichtig all das was
wir jetzt machen zu befristen bis zum 30
juni dass es auch nicht darüber hinaus
erst einmal geht und wir adressieren da
verschiedene punkte es geht da zum einen
um verbraucher bei dauerschuldverhältnis
zu schützen dass ihnen nicht der strom
das internet das wasser abgestellt wird
dort können sie für drei monate etwas
luft schnappen die zahlungen einstellen
wir wollen eigentümer auch andere
verbraucher schützen die darlehen
aufgenommen haben etwa wenn sie ihr haus
finanziert haben dass sie für die
nächsten drei monate ihre kreditraten
keine zinsen mehr zahlen müssen keine
tilgung mehr leisten müssen weil wir
verhindern wollen dass dort versteckt
wird in das eigentum und der letzte
punkt der glaube ich die meisten
menschen insbesondere interessiert das
ist der bereich des mietrechts weil es
dort wirklich um existenzielle fragen
gibt wir wollen nicht dass menschen das
dach über dem kopf verlieren denn es ist
für sie existenziell
es ist ein stück rückzugsort es ist ein
stück heimat und deswegen gehen wir hin
und sagen bis zum 30 juni wird der
kündigungsschutz hochgefahren wegen
mietschulden darf man in dieser zeit
nicht mehr kündigen war es aber auch den
kollegen legen wir muten den vermietern
einiges zu damit und man muss schon sagt
auch die haben natürlich sorgen viele
gerade die privaten vermieter die sind
auch darauf an
wiesen mietzahlungen zu erhalten weil
sie etwa ihre altersvorsorge darauf
aufgebaut haben und deswegen haben wir
als union sehr darauf geachtet dass wir
das gesetz an dieser stelle nicht nur
befristet sondern wir haben auch gesagt
es muss auch dringend notwendig sein
dass mieterinnen und mieter nachweisen
dass sie glaubhaft machen dass sie
wirklich gerade aufgrund von corona in
diese wirtschaftliche notlage kommen sie
und deswegen ihre mietzahlung machen
wir sind zwei punkte die ich ganz kurz
nur adressieren möchte wichtig der
zahlungsanspruch der bleibt
selbstverständlich bestehen wieder
müssen ihre miete zahlen nach zahlen
etwa auch verzug zinsen zahlen deswegen
glaube ich dass ist wichtig die
mietwagen nur diejenigen die wirklich in
wirtschaftliche not macht bitte davon
gebrauch und denkt insofern auch an eure
vermieter und der letzte punkt der
grundsatz der subsidiarität neben
staatliche hilfen in anspruch wohngeld
alg2 die staatlichen hilfsprogramme
wir wollen keinen dominoeffekt auslösen
sondern wir wollen die wirtschaft am
laufen halten das insofern die
staatlichen hilfsprogramme bitte in
anspruch nehmen dass die miete auch
weiter gezahlt werden kann
es sind höher sollte genug sagt ich
komme mir zum schluss es ja besondere
zeiten das erfordert besondere lösungen
wir wollen ein stück weit hoffnung und
zuversicht geben mit diesem gesetz und
deswegen bitte ich hier an dieser stelle
um zustimmung vielen dank stephan thomae
fdp
sehr geehrter herr präsident werde
kollegin verehrte kollegin meine damen
und herren in krisenlagen wie dieser
weiß ich dass die verlässlichkeit
unserer rechtsstaatlichen gewalt
arrangements der freiheitlich
demokratischen rechtsstaat kennt keinen
ausnahmezustand
das rechts wird in diesen tagen vielfach
einer bewährungsprobe ausgesetzt aber
freiheit eigentum privatautonomie müssen
wir auch und gerade in diesen zeiten
schützen wenn wir unser land nach dieser
krise noch wiedererkennen wollen auch in
krisen wie dieser muss der rechtsstaat
erkennbar bleiben damen und herren und
liegt uns die bundesregierung heute ein
gesetzespaket mit vielen zum teil tief
greifenden änderungen im insolvenzrecht
im zivilrecht mich strafverfahrensrecht
vor überwiegend sehen wir diese
änderungsvorschläge als sachgerecht und
angemessen an
aber teilweise den wiener auch kritisch
und teilweise auch ablehnend gegenüber
wir haben die zeiten verlangen ist das
gerichtsverfahren länger als bisher
ausgesetzt werden müssen dass
hauptverhandlungen von gesellschaften
wohnungseigentümergemeinschaften von
vereinen nicht weiß präsenz sitzungen
stattfinden können ja unternehmen droht
die zahlungsunfähigkeit und verbraucher
und kleinstunternehmer sind nicht mehr
lagen wie bisher dauer verträge mieten
und pachten und darlehen weiter zu
bezahlen
das verlangt von uns dass wir darauf
reagieren dass wir unbedingt der
einnahmeausfälle dass sie verlustängsten
und dass wir den ängste dass manche vor
dem nichts steht entgegen wirken ja
verbraucher und mieter brauchen schutz
und hilfe in diesen tagen aber frau
ministerin manche maßnahme die sie
ergreifen die reicht das problem nur
eine reihe weiter und das ist das
problem 22 vorschlägen die sie machen
zum einen bei dem leistungs
verweigerungsrecht bei
dauerschuldverhältnis verhältnissen sie
sprachen es an wein stehen gewaltige
unsicherheiten
und diese unsicherheit und treffen vor
allem kleinstunternehmer vor allem
handwerker stärker als viele anderen und
das zweite problem ist sie sprachen es
ebenfalls schon an und es war gegenstand
der meisten vorredner von mir ist des
kündigungsrechts im mietrecht 3,9
millionen private kleinvermieter in
diesem land sind darauf angewiesen was
miete gezahlt wird
ansonsten droht auch ihnen dass sie
darlehen nicht mehr bezahlen können dass
die betriebskosten nicht mehr bezahlen
können dass die verwalter gebühren und
handwerkerrechnungen schuldig bleiben
bleibt die miete aus dann hängt eine
ganze menge hinten dran dann drohen
vielleicht irgendwann darlehens
kündigungen dann kann die
zwangsverwaltung die zwangsversteigerung
drohen dann droht der verlust eines
stückes altersvorsorge und das ist die
sorge die wir haben
deswegen hat die fdp vielleicht zu einer
schließung sun trag ihnen heute
vorgelegt der genau dem entgegenwirken
soll ein sonder hohen geld einführen
soll damit schon der erste dominostein
in dieser kaskade nicht fällt das die
mieter ihre miete weiter bezahlen können
dass die kette die dominokette mieter
vermieter darlehensgeber handwerker
verwalter gar nicht erst umwelt wir
haben also kritik an ihrem entwurf aber
wenn wir heute ihren gesetzentwurf
gleichwohl zustimmen dann tun wir dies
aus staatlicher verantwortung weil er
uns bewusst ist dass wir diese krise nur
gemeinsam welt gehen können ich danke
ihnen
mit schleppern die linke ist der nächste
welt machen
der präsident sicherte kolleginnen und
kollegen sehr geehrte damen und herren
die krone krise zeigt uns deutlich auf
dass die parlamentarische demokratie
sehr wohl handlungsfähig ist
gleichzeitig dürfen wir aber bei aller
gebotenen eile nicht vernachlässigen
alle maßnahmen auf die einschränkung von
grundrechten hin zu prüfen
die gewählten wege müssen stets das
betone ich das mildeste eingriffs mittel
seien nicht alle vorschläge in dieser
krise haben sich durch die gebotene
milde und zweckmäßigkeit ausgezeichnet
der hier vorliegende entwurf eines
gesetzes zur abmilderung der folgen der
korona epidemie in zivil insolvenz und
strafverfahrensrecht ist trotz bei uns
bestehende bedenken im ganzen
zustimmungsfähig die kritische aber
konstruktive begleitung ihrer vorhaben
das ist unser beitrag als opposition zur
bekämpfung der aktuellen krise wir
begrüßen daher insbesondere die
regelungen für mieterinnen und mieter
die aktuell ihre miete nicht zahlen
können diese sind durch das vorliegende
gesetz vor der kündigung des
mietvertrages geschützt so weit die
fehlende zahlung der miete auf der krise
beruht gleiches gilt für die verträge
über lieferung von strom gas und wasser
das finden wir gut
wir begrüßen auch den schutz vor
kündigung von hypotheken verträgen
soweit dort ebenfalls zahlungen
krisenbedingt nicht geleistet werden
können
für uns als linke stehen alle wohnen
verträge unter besonderem schutz und
gerade deshalb fordern wir weitergehende
als sie das unabhängig von der jetzigen
krise niemand seine wohnung von ihren
daten wir sehen daher dieses gesetz als
bloße verschiebung einer grundsätzlichen
politischen frage die da lautet warum
wird wohnraum zur verfügung gestellt und
diese frage beantworten wir ohne wenn
und aber
damit menschen darin wohnen können und
nicht damit dass aus kapital mehr
kapital wird
es ist aufgabe des staates und seiner
föderalen institutionen wohnraum zu
schaffen und im öffentlichen eigentum zu
halten anders werden wir niemals das
wohnraum problem für weite teile der
bevölkerung lösen können
im bereich der insolvenzordnung bedarf
es aus unserer sicht in den nächsten
wochen eine nachschärfung der
vorschriften
unsere angst ist dass die jetzigen
regelungen ausgenutzt werden können um
unternehmen wirtschaftlich auszuhöhlen
und gezielt in eine insolvenz zu führen
was ganz klar zum nachteil der dort
beschäftigten gehen würde
wir haben hierzu einige hinweise aus dem
bereich der insolvenzverwalter erhalten
die wir sehr ernst nehmen
als richter ist mir aber ein punkt
besonders wichtig nämlich die frage der
strafverfahren und gerichtsprozesse es
kommt darauf an dass die jetzt
beschlossenen regelungen zur fortführung
von ausgesetzten prozessen möglichst
unter berücksichtigung des wichtigen
grundsatzes der mündlichen möglichkeit
der verhandlung geführt werden
hier muss ich leider feststellen dass
die von ihnen vorgelegten regelungen
diesen grundsatz wenig gerecht wird
besser wäre es gewesen weniger verfahren
zu hemmen und mehr verfahren auszusetzen
so dass die prozesse unbelastet von der
gegenwärtigen krise neu eingeführt würde
wir sind aber insgesamt bei aller kritik
geneigt auch hier die regierung zu
unterstützen werden aber uns unsere
kritischen anmerkungen weiter
vorbehalten danke
nächste rednerin ich die kollegin
manuela rottmann bündnis 90 die grünen
[Applaus]
sehr geehrter herr präsident
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen unsere
wirtschaft muss einen drastischen shop
bewältigen und in normalzeiten völlig
gesunde unternehmen kämpfen jetzt
unverschuldet um ihre liquidität die
aussetzung der insolvenzantragspflicht
in dieser situation ist richtig und auch
die erleichterung der zuführung von
liquidität an schwankende unternehmen
durch gesellschafter oder gläubiger
erhalten damit die uhr für einen moment
an wir halten sie an für die
unternehmerinnen und unternehmer die
verantwortungsbewusst mit dieser
situation umgehen
diejenigen die an ihre arbeitgeber und
arbeitnehmer denken die an eigene
reserven gehen um ihren lieferanten zu
helfen oder um forderungen gegenüber
ihren kunden stunden zu können denen
helfen wir mit diesen eingriff -
insolvenzrecht denen danken wir dafür
dass auch sie so verantwortungsvoll mit
dieser krise umgehen
die erleichterungen im insolvenzrecht
bergen allerdings auch risiken und
darauf will ich hin weisen sie können
missbraucht werden
und deswegen ist es unerlässlich dass
staatliche hilfen mit klaren
vollstreckbaren auflagen versehen werden
wir müssen in dieser situation
verhindern dass die erleichterungen im
insolvenzrecht benutzt werden um die
renditen von kurzfristigen investoren zu
verbessern anstatt unsere unternehmen zu
stabilisieren die befristete aussetzung
der kündigung wegen ausstehender
mietzahlungen für nicht leistungsfähige
verbraucherinnen und verbraucher und
kleinstunternehmer ist für uns mit sagt
war das leistungs verweigerungsrecht für
wesentliche dauerschuldverhältnis greift
jedoch tief in die bewährte
risikoverteilung das allgemein schuld
rechts ein und auch das birgt risiken
klare regelung zu den darlegungs
pflichten hätten der praxis die
rechtssichere anwendung erleichtert
eine klare aussage zur gegen
leistungspflicht wären notwendig gewesen
eine bloße kaschieren von
zahlungspflichten birgt die gefahr
spätere überschuldung und hier müssen
wir über andere lösungen nachdenken zum
beispiel über sonderkündigungsrechte für
nicht wesentliche leistungen dieses
paket kann nur ein erster schritt sein
wir brauchen auch ein signal dafür dass
es nach der krise weitergeht die ohnehin
geplante verkürzung der frist bis zur
restschuldbefreiung vorzuziehen wäre ein
solches starkes signal
lassen sie mich noch kurz ein wort zu
den änderungen im infektionsschutzgesetz
sagen die später beraten werden an die
nächsten beratungen wurden wenig
beteiligt
es ist richtig dass der bundestag
entscheidet ob eine epidemische notlage
von nationalem ausmaß entsteht und nicht
die bundesregierung aber ein
demokratischer rechtsstaat kann muss und
wird zeigen dass sich eine solche krise
auch mit demokratischen und
rechtsstaatlichen mitteln bewältigen
lässt
es ist für mich aber nicht gut und nicht
verständlich dass der bundestagwahl
erlass von rechtsordnungen die tief in
die grundrechte eingreifen nicht
beteiligt ist
in diesem gesetz dass wir gerade
behandeln ist das anders hier haben wir
das geändert aber warum uns dann bei
tiefen eingriffen in die grundrechte im
infektionsschutzgesetz nicht genauso
macht ist für mich nicht verständlich
finde ich komm ich kurz zurück zu der
namentlichen abstimmung zu
tagesordnungspunkt 4 a die ersten 30
minuten sind inzwischen vorüber so dass
ich nun die abgeordneten deren nachnamen
mit den anfangsbuchstaben l bis z
daran erinnere dass sie auch zur
abstimmung gehen auch die nicht alle auf
einmal aber in den nächsten 30 minuten
natürlich können alle kolleginnen und
kollegen und soll noch in den nächsten
30 minuten ihre stimmkarte die uni werk
in die urne werfen jetzt erteile ich das
wort der kollegin dr vogel spd
sehr geehrter herr präsident liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen das motto
dieser krise ist ja abstand halten und
trotzdem zusammenhalten ich glaube das
passt ganz gut zu unserem thema was wir
hier debattieren
und ich denke wir zeigen heute auch hier
dass das gut gelingen kann
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen ja es ist
schon gesagt worden in einer krise ist
zunächst einmal die regierung gefordert
und deswegen beginne ich auch mit einem
ganz herzlichen dankeschön und ich denke
das mache ich nicht nur für die
spd-bundestagsfraktion ein dankeschön an
das bundesministerium der justiz und für
verbraucherschutz ganz persönlich auch
an die bundesministerin liebe christine
lambrecht und an das ganze team ist
wurde unter hochdruck mit viel
kreativität aber auch trotz des
hochdrucks mit viel sorgfalt ein paket
entwickelt dass wir heute hier zur
beratung haben und hoffentlich
beschließen werden
und da wurden sicherlich auch die
bestehenden arbeitszeit regeln nicht
eingehalten deswegen ganz ganz
herzliches dankeschön und ich bitte auch
das weiterzugeben
aber ich will auch ganz deutlich sagen
über kolleginnen und kollegen es waren
nicht nur die regierung die gehandelt
hat sondern wir haben festgestellt dass
es sehr gut geklappt hat mit der
kommunikation mit uns mit den
abgeordneten mit den fraktionen mit dem
parlament mit den polit mit der
koalition aber auch mit der opposition
und ich war sehr zufrieden mit diesem
prozess denn sonst könnten wir heute
dieses gigantische paket auch gar nicht
hier verantwortungsvoll verabschieden
deswegen auch dafür ein ganz herzliches
dankeschön
tja liebe kolleginnen und kollegen das
sind durchaus gravierende änderungen die
wir vornehmen der bestehenden regeln
fristen werden geändert abläufe
schuldverhältnisse das ist schon
angesprochen das verhältnis von
schuldnerinnen und schuldnern zu den
gläubigern rechte und pflichten werden
verändert dass es alles nicht trivial
aber dieses paket begrenzt die änderung
auf das wirklich nötigste das können wir
sagen wir nehmen nur die regeln in den
blick und verändern sie die wir auch
verändern müssen um diese krise zu
bewältigen erstens und zweitens das ist
befristet zunächst einmal bis zum 30
juni also drei monate das ist auch ein
guter ansatz dann können wir weiter
sehen gegebenenfalls von der
und das dritte möchte ich erwähnen bei
all den regelungen die wir hier vor
gesehen haben muss immer nachgewiesen
werden dargelegt werden jedenfalls ein
zusammenhang bestehen zu der korona
krise wir regeln das insolvenzrecht in
nötiger weise die fristen neu
strafprozess ist schon angesprochen
worden präsenz pflichten im
gesellschaftsrecht und die dauer
schuldverhältnisse das ist sicherlich
die gravierendste änderung ich möchte
auch noch mal sagen weil das der
spd-bundestagsfraktion natürlich
besonders wichtig ist das mietrecht und
zwar nicht nur privatwohnungen sondern
auch gewerberäume wir schützen
mieterinnen und mieter davor wegen
zahlungsverzug gekündigt zu werden und
das ist eine ganz zentrale ganz
wesentliche regelung in diesem
gesetzespaket dafür herzlichen dank dass
wir das so miteinander besprechen
konnten und hoffentlich hier
verabschieden
und natürlich liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen konnten nicht alle anmerkungen
berücksichtigt werden jetzt kommen erst
die ganzen stellungnahmen wir konnten
nicht alle fachlichen hinweise schon
aufgreifen deswegen habe ich überhaupt
kein problem damit heute hier zu sagen
wir nehmen uns das noch mal vor wir
können anpassen wir können nachbessern
vielleicht schaffen wir das schon zur
nächsten sitzungswoche im april ich
denke da haben wir an der einen oder
anderen stelle noch gelegenheit dazu
jedenfalls zeigen wir mit diesem
gesetzespaket wir haben einen starken
rechtsstaat und er bleibt auch stark und
wird noch stärker durch die krise und
ich bitte sie herzlich und zustimmung zu
diesem paket vielen dank florian jacoby
anschlägen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
herr präsident meine damen und herren
artikel 1 des vorliegenden gesetzes soll
die insolvenzantragspflicht und weitere
insolvenzrechtliche folgen aussetzen das
tragen wir als af der umsatz mit wer in
dieser völlig unübersehbaren lage um
sein unternehmen und um die
arbeitsplätze seiner mitarbeiter kämpft
der soll bis auf weiteres nicht auch
noch mit der strafbewehrten pflicht zur
stellung eines insolvenzantrags
zusätzlich belastet werden ähnliches
gilt für die werde ich in ungewisser
lage entscheiden müssen ob sie die im
unternehmen privates kapital zur
verfügung stellen um es über diese krise
zu retten
wie gesagt wir tragen das heute mit
allerdings ist es nicht unsere aufgabe
nur maßnahmen der regierung abzudecken
sondern ein paar große aber anzufügen
erstens die verbände der insolvenz
sachverständigen haben hinweise
mitgeteilt die in der extremen kürze der
zeit nicht ausreichend eingegangen
werden konnte
das muss beobachtet und womöglich sehr
schnell nachgebessert werden
zweitens die regierung soll ermächtigt
werden die vorgesehene dauer der
maßnahme von sechs monaten noch um ein
weiteres halbes jahr zu verlängern bis
ins nächste jahr hinein
der gesetzgeber darf sich aber nicht so
weitgehend aus der verantwortung ziehen
diese entscheidung muss das parlament
treffen wenn sie ansteht wir haben den
antrag gestellt diese ermächtigung zu
streichen
bitte stimmen sie dem zu drittens die
insolvenzantragspflicht hat eine
wichtige funktion nicht tragfähige
unternehmen müssen aus den
wirtschaftsprozess entfernt nicht als
untote zombies künstlich weiter
geschleppt werden
schon in der bankenkrise wurde diese
funktion beeinträchtigt durch aufweichen
des überschuldungsbegriffs auch damals
hieß es das gelte nur vorübergehend in
einer akuten krise
das wurde dann mehrfach verlängert und
schließlich ganz unauffällig auf dauer
gestellt
wir werden darauf achten dass dieser
fehler nicht wiederholt wird
viertens apropos überschuldung durch die
heutigen maßnahmen so nötig sie sein
mögen
werden die staatsfinanzen für die
absehbare zukunft derart belastet das
nicht unabdingbare ausgaben schlicht
unmöglich sein werden seien es die
vielen millionen für dekadente gander
professoren seien es die vielen
milliarden für die asyl industrie das
alles ist nach dieser krise vorbei wir
werden hier sein um den rest des hauses
bei zeiten daran erinnern
drucker heribert hirte cdu csu nicht
[Applaus]
präsident liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
möchte vielleicht am anfang noch einmal
daran erinnern was eigentlich die zwei
wesentlichen punkte sind die alle diese
änderungen im zivil- straf- und
wirtschaftsrecht verbinden
es geht einmal darum und die kollegen
rottmann hat darauf eben hingewiesen
zeit zu gewinnen zeit für gewinnen zum
nachdenken was die endgültige auch die
endgültige verteilung der lasten im
bereich des zivil- und wirtschaftsrecht
sein muss und das ist ein bisschen
ähnlich wie das was wir im
gesundheitsbereich auf tun wo wir sehen
dass wir überfordert sind wenn wir
sofort sagen würden wir wissen genau wie
es gehen soll
das wissen wir nicht und in dieser
unsicherheit und so steht es im übrigen
auch bei den haushaltsmäßigen auf den
haushaltsmäßigen ausführung bei uns im
gesetzentwurf drin
diese unsicherheit müssen wir offen
zugeben und in dieser unsicherheit mit
dieser unsicherheit handeln werde und
der zweite punkt der kollege hat sehr
deutlich angesprochen
wir fangen bei den schwächsten gliedern
an das sind die unternehmen das sind die
familien dass sie die privatperson wenn
ein unternehmen erst mal pleite ist
ausgeschieden aus dem markt dann kann es
nicht einfach wieder belebt werden
eine familie die ihre wohnung verlassen
musste kann nicht irgendwann später
wieder rein
deshalb schützen wir erst hier wir
werden mit sicherheit in dieser regress
kette in dieser dominokette noch einmal
darüber nachdenken müssen wie wir bei
den weiteren aspekten wie wir mit diesen
punkten umzulegen haben das
bundesjustizministerium wir haben es
gerade gehört sammelt die entsprechenden
anregen lassen sich aber dann zu den
beiden wirtschaftsrechtlichen aspekten
insolvenzrecht und gesellschaftsrecht
noch etwas sagen
im insolvenz nicht setzen wir wir hatten
dafür vorbilder bei den verschiedenen
hochwasserkatastrophen die
insolvenzantragspflicht die
strafbewehrung der
insolvenzantragspflicht für einige
monate aus die unternehmen haben von vor
einigen wochen als das in china los ging
uns gesagt müssen wir nicht
insolvenzantrag stellen wir haben ein
strafbares risiko dieses risiko diese
sorge nehmen die
dass er ganz ganz wichtiger schritt um
die unternehmen am leben zu erhalten
und zweitens wir gehen hin die und
schaffe die regelungen ab die
haftungsregeln ab wir mildern die
haftungsregeln ab die damit verbunden
sind dass geschäftsführer in dieser zeit
keine zahlungen mehr leisten dürfen und
dass umgekehrt möglicherweise in einer
insolvenz die später kommt die zahlungen
jetzt geleistet werden mit der
insolvenzanfechtung rückgängig gemacht
werden müssen das ist der zusammenhang
ein letzter punkt die
restschuldbefreiung kann auch nicht auf
zahlungsunfähigkeit auf
krisensituationen in der jetzigen
situation geschützt werden zu recht
haben einige insolvenzverwalter alle von
uns angesprochen oder das wurde schon
mehrfach gesagt dass auch missbrauch
droht wir beobachten das sehr genau und
dieser missbrauch droht vor allen dingen
deshalb weil in der bestimmung der
zentralen bestimmungen drinsteht dass
seit dem ersten januar die
zahlungsunfähigkeit die insolvenzreife
dass es vermutet wird dass sie auf
polona bedingte sachverhalte zurückgeht
da muss man erklären warum wir dieses
datum gewählt haben
wir haben es in abstimmung mit dem
finanzministerium gewählt weil es genau
das datum ist von dem an hilfen
beantragt werden können und es kann
nicht sein dass man insolvenz wird wie
erwähnt wird auf der einen seite wenn
hilfen möglicherweise gewährt werden
können aber umgekehrt bedeutet das wenn
keine hilfe gewährt wird weil die
kausalität woanders liegt dann besteht
natürlich auch das risiko der insolvenz
das müssen wir deutlich sagen und
andererseits unternehmen nur mit einem
lokalen markt da wird sich die frage
anders stellen als bei internationalen
unternehmen die von lieferketten
abhängig sind
also wir schauen da hin und der nächste
punkt gesellschaftsrecht es wurde gesagt
wir führen jetzt erst aber befristete
aber dass ein wichtiger punkt eine
virtuelle hauptversammlung ein
hier brauchten wir einen ausgleich mit
den interessen der aktionäre
und ich sage ganz deutlich das
fragerecht müssen wir genau ansehen ob
das hier auch so behandelt wird so
gewährleistet wird wie es gerade vor dem
hintergrund des eigentums schutzes in
präsenz hauptversammlung gewährt wird
das ist ein wichtiger punkt der
vielleicht verbesserungsfähig ist aber
wir sehen andererseits das risiko das
auf corona gestützte anfechtungsklagen
erhoben werden sollen das haben wir
ausgeschlossen
insofern ein richtiger und wichtiger
schritt ich danke wünsche allen die
erkrankt sind gute genesung
ihnen bleiben sie gesund vielen dank und
ich bitte um zustimmung für das gesetz
voraussichtlich letzte redner in dieser
debatte der kollege dr folge ulrich cdu
csu herr präsident meine sehr verehrten
damen und herren die wirtschaftlichen
verwerfungen durch die korona krise sind
eine große herausforderung für unsere
rechtsordnung wenn vieles stillsteht ist
das nichts anderes als eine
gesellschaftliche wegfall der
geschäftsgrundlage und rechten und
lebenswirklichkeit lassen sich nicht
voneinander trennen
das wären spannen wir heute einen
rechtlichen schutzschirm über vielerlei
vertragsbeziehungen auf es geht darum
dass wir die schwächsten besonders
schützen und dass wir zeit gewinnen um
aus der krise herauszukommen
im wesentlichen geht es darum dass wir
im mietrecht die mieterinnen und mieter
stärker schützen wollen es besteht durch
dieses gesetz keinen anspruch darauf
die miete nicht zu bezahlen aber wenn
jemand corona bedingt die miete nicht
bezahlen kann
da muss er nicht fürchten gekündigt zu
werden ich glaube dass es ein wichtiges
signal in schwierigen zeiten
aber klar ist auch dass wir ein
interessenausgleich brauchen wir müssen
auch an die kleinen vermieter denken die
abhängig sind von den mieteinnahmen um
ihre darlehen zu bedienen und auch hier
gilt dass wir das darlehen nicht
bedienen kann der muss nicht sofort
angst haben dass das ganze darlehen
fällig gestellt wird und er damit
zahlungsunfähig wird
hier liegt man damen und herren ein
wichtiger interessenausgleich wir wissen
doch sprechen
über die frage des insolvenzrechts
gerade in schwierigen zeiten kommt es
darauf an zeit zu gewinnen und geld
einzunehmen doch hilfs vor oder durch
zeitliche streckung um den
geschäftsbetrieb aufrecht zu halten
ein insolvenzantrags frist von nur drei
wochen kommt dieser krise nicht den
geben deswegen wird es verlängert und es
sorgen auch dafür dass die unternehmen
handlungsfähig bleiben handlungsfähig
indem sie die beschlüsse treffen können
die notwendig sind
zur bilanzierung aber auch zur
ausschüttung des bilanzgewinns deswegen
führen wir eine virtuelle
hauptversammlung ein und ja das hat
änderungen in bezug auf die wahrnehmung
der rechte des minderheitsaktionärs aber
ich glaube auch dass wir hier einen
guten interessenausgleich finden um
unternehmen in schwierigen zeiten
handlungsfähig zu gestalten
und ja meine damen und herren das ganze
muss zeitlich begrenzt sein
weil eine ausnahmesituation nicht die
regel werden darf so wie wir auch in
anderen punkten sehr besonnen umgehen
müssen
ich glaube dass diese krise und das habe
die beratung heute deutlich gemacht
keine krise des rechts ist weil alle
eingriffe in grundrechte verhältnismäßig
sind weil sie zeitlich begrenzt sind
weil sie gut begründet werden und weil
mir damit zum ausdruck bringen dass
unsere freiheitlich-demokratische
ordnung auch mit einer situation im
rahmen des rechts umgehen kann und das
ist die wichtige botschaft dass wir
durch recht und gesetzmäßigkeit auch an
die krise bewältigen können deswegen
bitte ich sie um zustimmung
damit schließt sich die aussprache und
wir kommen zur abstimmung über den von
den fraktionen der cdu/csu und spd
eingebrachten gesetzentwurf zur
abmilderung der folgen der kobik 19
pandemie
sie will insolvenz und
strafverfahrensrecht der ausschuss für
recht und verbraucherschutz empfiehlt in
seiner beschlussempfehlung auf den
drucks auf den drucksachen 18 129 und 18
158 den gesetzentwurf der fraktionen der
cdu und spd auf der drucksache 1810 in
der ausschuss fassung anzunehmen wird
hierzu liegen sechs änderungsanträge vor
über die wir zuerst abstimmen ich rufe
auf den änderungsantrag der fraktion der
af der drucksache 18 134 wer stimmt für
diesen änderungsantrag wer stimmt
dagegen wäre enthält sich dann ist
dieser änderungsantrag gegen die stimmen
der afg mit den stimmen des übrigen
hauses abgelehnt dann rufe ich auf den
änderungsantrag der fraktionen der afc
der drucksache 18 135
das stimmt für diesen änderungsantrag
wer stimmt dagegen wäre enthält sich
dann ist auch dieser änderungsantrag
gegen die stimme der afg mit den stimmen
des übrigen hauses abgelegt und ich rufe
auf den änderungsantrag der fraktionen
der chef der drucksache 18 136 er stimmt
für diesen antrag stimmt dagegen während
hält sich dann ist auch dieser antrag
gegen die stimmen der afg mit den
stimmen des übrigen hauses abgelehnt ich
rufe auf den änderungsantrag der
fraktion die linke auf der drucksache 18
137 jahre stimmt dafür dass sind dagegen
wäre enthält sich dann ist dieser antrag
bei enthaltung der fraktion die gruppe
bündnis 90 die grünen gegen die stimmen
der linken mit den stimmen des übrigen
hauses abgelehnt und ich rufe auf den
änderungsantrag der fraktionen die linie
auf der drucksache 18 138 mehr stimmt
dafür sind dagegen
während hält sich dann ist auch dieser
antrag bei enthaltung von bündnis 90
gegen die stimmen der linken mit den
stimmen des übrigen hauses abgelehnt und
ich rufe auf den änderungsantrag der
fraktionen die linke auf der drucksache
aktion 139 bestimmt dafür
es stimmt dagegen wer enthält sich dann
ist auch dieser antrag mit denselben
mehrheitsverhältnissen wie die beiden
letzten abgelehnt und nur bin ich
diejenige die die gesetze dorf der
fraktionen der cdu/csu und spd auf der
drucksache 110 in der ausschuss fassung
zustimmen wollen und das anzeichen
wer stimmt dagegen während hält sich
dann ist der ausschuss dann ist der
gesetzentwurf in zweiter lesung
einstimmig angenommen wir kommen zur
dritten beratung und schlussabstimmung
und ich bitte diejenigen die mit entwurf
zustimmen wollen nicht zu erheben
darin gesehen wer stimmt dagegen
enthaltungen
dann ist der gesetzentwurf in der
beratung einstimmig angenommen jetzt
kommt er zur abstimmung
21 oder 22
in zweiter und dritter lesung ich bitte
um entschuldigung dass ich muss sehen
dass der nachteil dass die schriftführer
abstandsgebot nicht neben mir sitzen ich
vermisse sie auch sehr also bei zwei
enthaltungen aus der fraktion der fc st
jetzt kommen wir zur abstimmung über die
entschließungsanträge entschließung der
fraktion der fdp drucksache 18 140 wer
stimmt dafür bestimmt dagegen enthält
sich eines dieser entschließungsantrag
gegen die stimmen der afc mit den
stimmen des übrigen hauses abgewählt
dann komme ich zum ende
entschließungsantrag der fraktionen der
fdp auf der drucksache 18 141 wäre
stimmt dafür
es stimmt dagegen er enthält sich dieser
änderungsantrag ist gegen die stimmen
der fdp bei enthaltung von bündnis 90
die grünen mit den stimmen des übrigen
haus ist abgelehnt
und jetzt komme ich zum
entschließungsantrag natürlichkeit
änderung sagen dass wir hier und jetzt
komme ich zum entschließungsantrag der
fraktionen die linke auf der drucksache
18 142 wer stimmt dafür bestimmt dagegen
enthält sich dieser entschließungsantrag
ist bei enthaltung von bündnis 90 die
grünen gegen die stimmen der linken mit
den stimmen des übrigen hauses abgelehnt
und bevor ich jetzt zu
tagesordnungspunkt 6 a bis h komme sage
ich jetzt haben wir noch etwa zehn
minuten die ordnung geöffnet wer also an
der namentlichen abstimmung zu 815
teilnehmen möchte und so nicht getan hat
sollte es in absehbarer zeit in den
nächsten zehn minuten tun dann um sich
auf die tagesordnungspunkte 6a bis sechs
zweite und dritte beratung der von den
fraktionen der cdu/csu und spd
eingebrachten gesetzentwürfe zum schutze
der bevölkerung bei einer epidemischen
lage von nationaler tragweite
bitte denken sie ans abstandsgebot auch
beim platzwechsel besteht infizierung
gefahr
also machen sie es ein bisschen wir
haben außerdem die zweite beratung der
gesetze würfe von cdu csu und spd zum
ausgleich sowie 19 bedingt der
finanzieller belastungen der
krankenhäuser und weiteren
gesundheitseinrichtungen und für den
erleichterten zugang zu sozialer
sicherung und zum einsatz zur
absicherung sozialer dienstleistungen
aufgrund des corona wieder stars co2
sowie die beratung von fünf vorlagen der
fraktion der afg zu maßnahmen gegen die
aus wegen der korona krise
es liegen ein änderungsantrag und
mehrere entschließungsanträge vor für
die aus spanischer eine dauer von 30
minuten beschlossen
ich eröffne die aussprache unter teil
des vor den kollegen georg nüßlein cdu
csu
[Applaus]
herr präsident meine damen meine herren
das land der selbstverständlichkeiten
hält die eu an
plötzlich macht jeder was wir vorher nur
ein paar wochen für selbstverständlich
gehalten haben war es noch nie freiheit
wohlstand wachstum noch wichtiger aber
gesundheit und gesundheitsversorgung
es wird nicht an wenn großeltern fragen
waren kommst du wieder
es würde mich anwendern ein weinendes
kind metal ich will zum einen
spielkameraden
es wird nicht auch an wenn arbeitnehmer
wenn unternehmer fragen wie soll das
alles weitergehen da bewegt mich
natürlich am meisten dass wir alle diese
fragen noch nicht beantworten können
das wären heutigen tag nur die grobe
marschroute festlegen und noch mehr
bewegt mich uns alle aber die bilder
[Musik]
italienischen militärkonvoi es schwer
kranke patienten auf dem boden in
krankenhäusern in madrid bilder die wie
ein menetekel von geisterhand wegwischen
was uns an verharmlosung immer noch
entgegengehalten wird uns alle regierung
wie opposition ein ziel dass genau diese
bilder mit aller kraft zu verhindern und
schaden vom deutschen volke abzuwenden
das ist dreh und angelpunkt meine damen
und herren dieser gesetze die wir heute
debattieren dabei danke ich allen
konnten die konstruktiv mitgewirkt haben
opposition mit koalitions abgeordneten
wir mitarbeitern sie haben in den
letzten tagen nicht nur hart gearbeitet
sondern eine gemeinsame staatspolitische
verantwortung wagen um finden
der deutsche bundestag stellt heute im
bevölkerungsschutz gesetzt die
epidemische lage von nationaler
tragweite fest
es ist entscheidend dass wir das tun das
parlament und genauso entscheidend dass
wir die macht haben das und das
hoffentlich bald wieder aufzuheben
das bevölkerungsschutz gesetz ist die
grundlage für eingriffe in grundrechte
wie die körperliche unversehrtheit die
freiheit der person oder die
versammlungsfreiheit
das gesetz ermächtigt aber auch in
bundesgesundheitsminister umfassend und
situativ einzugreifen und insbesondere
gesundheitsversorgung zu gewährleisten
es ist meine damen und herren ein
unabdingbarer vertrauensvorschuss an den
gesundheitsminister
jens spahn hat in krisen management
größe gezeigt und dieses vertrauen schon
jetzt in ganz besonderer weise
gerechtfertigt
unser gesundheitssystem ist
überdurchschnittlich gut es ist aber
trotzdem nicht umfänglich auch eine
pandemie ausgelegt dafür nutzen wir die
zeit die wir mit den kontakt
beschränkungen gewinnen in der krise
kommt es in besonderer weise auf unsere
krankenhäuser auch die ärzte auf die
pflege an
für ihr engagement dank und anerkennung
krankenhäuser müssen momentan betten
freien halten intensivbetten anschaffen
wie hat kliniken müssen sich auf
akutpatienten und die kurzzeitpflege
umstellen ärzte ihre behandlungsweise um
stelle neu ausrichten
am geld meine damen und herren darf das
alles nicht scheitern
deshalb spannen wir auch für die
krankenhäuser rehakliniken und die
arztpraxen an milliardenschweren
rettungsschirm auf der bund beteiligt
sich mit 50.000 euro an jedem neuen
intensiv wird
mit beratungsmöglichkeit wir zahlen für
jedes freigehaltene bett 560 euro pro
tag für die rehakliniken 60 prozent des
durchschnittlichen vergütungssatzes
wir hören dass pflege budget pro tag und
patient auf 185 euro wir zahlen 50 oder
zuschlag pro patient für teurere
schutzausrüstung
dabei wünsche ich mir in der jetzigen
situation nichts mehr als dass wir all
das viele geld grundlos ausgeben dass
die betten leer bleiben und die
beatmungsgeräte verstauben in allem
gesundheit und gottes segen
jürgen pohl fdx etr
[Applaus]
danke schön herr präsident meine damen
und herren sehr geehrte kollegen die
korona krise hat unser land fest im
griff und in den schweren zeiten die wir
erwarten würde sich wieder zeigen die
wir gemeinsam leisten können um einen
nationalen katastrophenfall zu bekämpfen
und das von der koalitionsfraktion
vorgelegte soziale schutzpaket ist nur
ein anfang es hat stärken ist hat
schwächen aber ich erkläre ausdrücklich
meinen respekt in welcher
geschwindigkeit dieses maßnahmenpaket
vorgelegt wurde und diese
geschwindigkeit muss ich ihnen sagen die
ist gut wir brauchen diese
geschwindigkeit ja daraus schon
fehlentwicklungen in der sozialpolitik
rüth doch heute soll sich der tag des
parteipolitischen kleinklein sein aber
meine damen und herren
nach abschluss der krise wird die sache
wieder im griff haben und ich bin mir
sicher dass unser volk diese krise
positiv meistern wird müssen wir über
solche fragen sprechen wurde das corona
virus noch im januar 2002 sich
unterschätzt wurden die vorhandenen
pläne und szenarien für die zeit einer
pandemie überhaupt genügend beachtet
waren die technischen und personellen
voraussetzungen gegeben solche eine
pandemie zu beherrschen
aber das sind fragen die stehen später
sehr geehrte damen und herren sehr
geehrte bundesregierung sehr geehrter
herr minister es ist die zeit der
staatsbürgerlichen verantwortung aller
es ist an der zeit alle vorschläge zur
lösung dieser herausforderung zu prüfen
um damit not und unsere bevölkerung
abzuwenden
der fünf punkte plan der a steht will
die sozialen folgen der korona krise
bremsen dem wir
brauchen sie sofort wir brauchen noch
mehr unterstützung für familien eltern
und kinder bei schließung von schulen
und kindergärten mehr als von ihnen
beschlossen
wir brauchen noch bessere regelungen für
die landwirtschaft um die
lebensmittelversorgung der bevölkerung
sicherzustellen
wir brauchen eine änderung der
hinzuverdienstgrenzen bei der
grundsicherung
wir brauchen regelungen zum erhalten
lebensnotwendiger logik ist logistik zur
unterstützung der lkw-fahrer wir
brauchen einen notfallplan für
obdachlose menschen mit behinderung wir
brauchen ein sonderprogramm für
bundesfreiwilligendienst regelungen für
azubis das sind fragen die anstehen und
wir bieten an unsere unterstützung wir
haben dem entsprechende anträge heute
währung gestellt aber sehr geehrte
kollegen maximal mögliche hilfe verdient
insbesondere die alten menschen in
unserem land das sind die menschen die
deutschland nach den schweren kriegen im
zwanzigsten jahrhundert wieder aufgebaut
haben denen wir unseren wohlstand
verdanken und jede rechtliche regelung
die wir hier beschließen muss sich daran
messen lassen nutzt die unseren eltern
nutzt die unseren alten das muss wichtig
seien kurz zu einem gesetz zur
epidemischen lage von nationaler
tragweite
wir sind der meinung dass der
gesetzentwurf durchaus sinnvoll ist aber
wir sehen eine notwendigkeit dass im
gesetz eine automatische befristung der
geltungsdauer bis zum 30 2020 tode sie
ihn sein sollte so dass der bundestag
sich vor dem 30 19 20 21
mit diesem gesetz noch einmal
beschäftigt daher enthaltung auch beim
krankenhaus entlastungsgesetz haben wir
besprechungs bedarf insbesondere solche
formulierung wie zb dass kassenärztliche
vereinigung eine befristete
ausgleichszahlung an die
leistungserbringer leisten können nein
sie können nicht sie müssen diese
zahlung erbringen
sehr geehrte damen und herren wert
gelegen unser grundgesetz fußt auf dem
gedanken der gemeinschaft der
solidarität jetzt ist die zeit gekommen
an einem strang zu ziehen und
solidarität und gemeinsinn zu zeigen
jetzt zählt nur noch das 1 steht für die
familie für den nachbarn für die
gemeinschaft wir stimmen in sozial paket
zu dankeschön
liebe kollegen kollegen ich glaube
zurück zu tagesordnungspunkt 4
die zeit für die namentliche abstimmung
ist jetzt abgelaufen
die frage ist doch ein mitglied des
hauses irgendwo im haus das seine stimme
nicht abgegeben hat oder seine stimme
noch abgeben möchte wenn das nicht der
fall ist schließlich die abstimmung und
bitte die schriftrollen schriftführer
mit der auszahlung zu beginnen das
ergebnis der abstimmung erst später
bekanntgegeben werden und damit
beteiligt das wort in unserer aussprache
dem bundesminister hubertus heil
sehr geehrter herr präsident liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen beim schutz von
gesundheit geschütztes leben das hat
absolute priorität in dieser krise sind
verschiedenen reden deutlich geworden
denn diese herausforderung herr kollege
ist übrigens nicht nur eine nationale
katastrophe
es ist eine menschheit herausforderungen
und ich sage ihnen weil gesundheit
schutz von leib und leben
absolute priorität hat müssen wir
versuchen der bevölkerung wo immer es
geht andere existenzielle ängste zu
nehmen das betrifft die angst um das
kleine unternehmen das betrifft die
angst um den arbeitsplatz
das betrifft die angst um die soziale
sicherheit und ich sage ihnen diese
bundesregierung und diese demokratie das
zeigt sich ja heute wird alles tun um um
jeden arbeitsplatz um jede existenz zu
kämpfen wo die soziale sicherheit in
diesem land zu gewährleisten
die wirtschaftlichen folgen der
gesundheitspolitischen maßnahmen auch
der welt wirtschaftlichen auswirkungen
sind dramatisch und ich kann ihnen heute
nicht als arbeitsminister zu sagen
willst du wirklich jeden arbeitsplatz
sichern können aber ich kann ihnen
deutlich sagen wir werden um jeden
arbeitsplatz in deutschland kämpfen
wir haben dazu instrumente und mittel
die der deutsche bundestag heute im
rahmen der wirtschafts hilfen
bereitgestellt hat aber das betrifft
auch die arbeitsmarktpolitischen
instrumente die wir uns schon mal in der
krise geschafft haben um arbeitsplätze
zu sichern
ich rede von den veränderten regeln zur
kurzarbeit die wir als parlament und als
regierung jetzt sofort zur verfügung
haben das sichert beschäftigung es
sichert auch liquidität in den
unternehmen und das ist eine wichtige
botschaft an dieser stelle
das zweite was wir heute beschließen ist
dass wir auch zuverdienstmöglichkeiten
für menschen in kurzarbeit sind erhöhen
damit lohnlücke abgefordert werden ich
mach mal ein beispiel es gibt jetzt
viele menschen in der wäscherei arbeiten
die wäscherei hat keine aufträge weil
das hotel das sie sonst versorgen
geschlossen hat aber es werden
gleichzeitig viele menschen in einer
wäscherei in einem krankenhaus
beispielsweise gebraucht wir ermöglichen
ohne lohneinbußen dass diejenigen die
jetzt in kurzarbeit gehen tatsächlich in
diesem bereich auch tätig sein können
das kurzarbeitergeld wird dafür nicht
gestrichen
wir sorgen drittens
dafür dass es einer erleichterten zugang
für alle gibt die jetzt auf ergänzende
grundsicherung angewiesen sind
auch selbstständige oder
arbeitnehmerinnen arbeitnehmer wer
existenziell sozial gefährdet ist er
wird ab sofort befristet für diesen
zeitraum tatsächlich ohne
vermögensprüfung ohne überprüfungen von
wohnraum in den genuss von
grundsicherung kommen können der begriff
genuss ist vielleicht falsch sondern ich
will es anders sagen das wirkt jetzt wie
ein kombilohn damit die menschen nicht
unter eine existenzielle wasserlinie
gehen können und ich bin dankbar dass
wir das heute beschließen
wir haben familien durch veränderungen
zum kinderzuschlag die meine kollegin
franziska giffey in dieses gesetz
eingebracht hat gerade geringverdiener
und wir sorgen dafür dass auch die zeit
der schule und kita schließungen nicht
zu unverhältnismäßigen lohnkürzungen
führt durch maßnahmen die wir mit den
ländern besprochen haben und nicht
zuletzt wir sichern die soziale
infrastruktur die sozialen dienste die
wir zur bewältigung dieser krise
brauchen und auch einsetzen werden indem
wir einen schutzschirm spannen der dazu
sorgt dass zb diejenigen der
weiterbildung arbeiten bei der
beruflichen rehabilitation bei der
schuldnerberatung beim familienschutz in
der kinder und jugendarbeit die ganze
großartige soziale infrastruktur wir
haben von trägern und
wohlfahrtsverbänden mit eingesetzt
werden kann zur bewältigung dieser
großen herausforderung
präsident meine damen und herren
unser land ist ein starkes land und es
gibt ja den satz dass der krise sich der
charakter zeigt ich finde dass die
absolute mehrheit die meisten menschen
in diesem land unglaublichen charakter
zeigen
ich meine die menschen die sich an die
regeln halten die ihre mitmenschen
schützen wären wir dankbar sind dass sie
die einstellung nicht ins tal
lebensmittel ich meine diejenigen die
hart arbeiten ist es viel über pflege
und gesundheit gesprochen worden das
stimmt aber auch die in den behörden
die jetzt ackern die leben schützen die
soziale sicherheit gewährleisten und ich
nehme jetzt mal zwei gruppen bitte sehen
sie mir das nach ausdrücklich mal nach
vorne ich sag das jetzt mal das
ungewöhnliche diesem parlament ich danke
auch den mitarbeiterin mitarbeitern im
ministerium die jetzt nachtschichten
gemacht haben aber vor allen dingen auch
die mitarbeiterin mitarbeiter bei der
bundesagentur für arbeit bei anderen
behörden des bundes und der länder die
soziale sicherheit jetzt gewährleisten
das ist eine kritische in kostet
vergessen
und in der krise zeigt sich auch der
charakter unserer demokratie in allen
fraktionen dieses hauses sehr dankbar
dass für diese maßnahmen in kürzerer
zeit beraten und beschlossen haben wir
zeigen dass diese demokratie nicht
wehrlos ist dass wir die mittel haben
dass wir die möglichkeiten haben unsere
bevölkerung zu beschützen und
deutschland gut durch diese krise zu
bringen im gesundheitswesen durch die
ertüchtigung von medizin und
intensivmedizin durch die
krankenhausfinanzierung im bereich des
infektionsschutz und auch mit dem sozial
schutzpaket zeigt diese demokratie
demokratie ist manchmal langsamer als
andere aber demokratie ist nicht zu spät
wir sind handlungsfähig und dafür bin
ich allen fraktionen diesem haus sehr
dankbar meine damen und herren
gott schütze sie herzlichen dank michael
theurer fdp ist ein extremer herr
präsident sehr verehrte kolleginnen und
kollegen und zu erreichen in jeder
minute bange fragen vieler menschen
viele menschen haben angst um ihre
gesundheit viele um ihre berufliche
existenz und vielen geht die lösung zu
langsam
wir haben aber sichergestellt als
regierungsfraktionen und opposition hier
das beratung die sonst wochen dauern in
wenigen stunden und hier in einem tag
über die bühne gehen das ist unsere
staatspolitische verantwortung auch wir
danken den ministerien und den
kolleginnen und kollegen der regierung
tragenden fraktionen und wir sind froh
dass verbesserungen erreicht werden
konnten mehr flexibilität etwa bei der
arbeitszeit um dringend
versorgungsengpässe abzuwehren um die
medizinische versorgung sicherzustellen
zuverdienstgrenzen die erhöht werden wir
würden sie gerne ganz abschaffen die
kurzarbeit ganz wichtig um eben die
menschen in der beschäftigung zu sichern
aber auch die unternehmen zu erhalten
liquiditätssicherung ist das zentrale
thema und ja wir haben noch sorgen weil
in einigen bereich
sehen wir lücken weil für einige
unternehmen nämlich für die mit mehr als
zehn mitarbeitern und weniger als 250
mitarbeitern die hilfen aus unserer
sicht noch unzureichend sind wir
ermutigen sie herr minister heil dass
sie hier weiter gehen dass sie zb die
stundung von
sozialversicherungsbeiträgen zumindest
im ausnahmefall zu lassen so dass
dadurch liquidität gesichert werden kann
und wir möchten sie ermutigen die
überlassung regelungen der
arbeitnehmerüberlassung flexibel zu
handhaben dass zum beispiel bei der
produktion von beatmungsgeräten etwa
durch den weltmarktführer träger wo
dringend arbeitskräfte gebraucht werden
aus den unternehmen in denen gerade
arbeitskräfte nicht gebraucht hatten
dass die zur verfügung gestellt werden
können und meine damen und herren
sozialer schutz ist das eine
gesundheitsschutz das andere beim gesetz
zur feststellung der epidemie von
nationaler tragweite sind massive
eingriffe in grundfreiheiten in
grundrechte vorgesehen
wir sind der meinung dass dies nur durch
den parlamentsvorbehalt nur durch den
deutschen bundestag hier möglich ist
dass wir das feststellen jederzeit
aufheben können und dass das gesetz
befristet werden muss das war unsere
bedingungen unter der wir diesem gesetz
zustimmen können die wurde aufgenommen
wir bedanken uns dafür dass diese
wichtige kartelle hier realisiert werden
kann leidet darunter
in diesem zusammenhang ist es auch
wichtig dass die zwangsverpflichtung von
angehörende heilung für ärzte und
pflegekräfte aus dem gesetz
herausgenommen wurde
wir haben hier eine große
leistungsbereitschaft der angehörigen
der heilberufe und wir möchten an dieser
stelle ärztinnen und ärzten
pflegekräften und allen die in sozialen
diensten tätig sind ganz herzlich danken
dass sie ohne ansehen der person hier
tätig sind ich glaube die
zwangsverpflichtung wäre das falsche
signal gewesen deshalb herzlichen dank
dass dieser rausgenommen
ein letzter punkt meine damen und herren
die besserstellung finanziell der
krankenhäuser ist uns wichtig dass die
reha auf unseren druck mit aufgenommen
wurden dafür danken wir jetzt geht es
aber auch um die reale versorgung wir
bitten sie herr minister spanier
minister altmaier dass sie die
versorgung mit schutzmasken die
versorgung mit schutzkleidung dass die
versorgung mit desinfektionsmittel
sichergestellt wird und wir wissen das
muss eingeflogen werden aus china die
abhängigkeit von einem lieferland ist
hier das problem meine damen und herren
wir müssen jetzt auch mit der deutschen
industrie sprechen dass sie umstellen
dass die produktion hier im land
stattfindet denn eins ist klar
feuerwehrleute davon nicht ohne
atemschutz in ein brennendes haus
schicken und ärztinnen und ärzte und
pfleger nicht ohne entsprechende
schutzkleidung wenn ein virus so
infektiös ist bitte helfen sie mit dass
dieses problem zeitnah gelöst
susanne förster
die linke hat das nächste kind
[Applaus]
sehr geehrter herr präsident sehr
verehrte kolleginnen und kollegen das
gesetz zum bevölkerungsschutz und zur
pandemie bekämpfung ist notwendig aber
in diesen notsituationen brauchst keine
weiteren eingriffe in grundrechte und
ausgangssperren sondern es braucht mehr
demokratie und deswegen bin ich sehr
froh dass auch aufgrund unserer
intervention es gelungen ist dass es
keine selbstermächtigung der
bundesregierung gibt sondern dass das
parlament entscheidet ob eine
notsituation vorliegt oder nicht
zu kritisieren ist allerdings die
unterschiedliche geltungsdauer der
maßnahmen in den gesetzen die regelungen
zu notstand gelten für ein ganzes jahr
die regelungen zum sozialschutz
lediglich für ein halbes jahr sehr
verehrte bundesregierung das hängt genau
umgekehrt wäre ein schuh daraus geworden
und zum sozial schutzpaket hier war noch
bei unserer telefonschalte mit minister
heil am wochenende war ich noch guten
mutes und das ist eine gute regelung auf
den weg weil es wichtig ist in der krise
den zugang zu hartz iv deutlich zu
erleichtern
stinksauer war ich am montagnachmittag
als ich gesehen habe was das kabinett
uns da am montag noch für faule eier
rein verhandelt hat da ist was sich
nicht zu schade den schutz charakter des
arbeitszeitgesetzes auszuhöhlen und ich
rede hier nicht von der pflege und den
krankenhäusern wo es um pflege es um
leben und tod geht sondern um
saisonarbeiter um mitarbeiterinnen und
mitarbeiter in der ernährungsindustrie
und so weiter und sie sind sich auch
nicht zu schade
die regelungen für mini-jobs und die
zuverdienstmöglichkeiten bei hartz 4
auszuweiten
menschen die von hartz 4 und den zu
niedrigen kurzarbeitergeld nicht leben
können sollen dann zum spargelstechen
gehen oder was ist ihre vorstellung
nicht nur die wirtschaft auch die
menschen brauchen einen rettungsschirm
und dafür müssen die regelsätze zu
mindestens vorübergehend erhöht werden
in die tafeln sind geschlossen
kurzarbeit
auf 90 prozent aufgestockt werden wie
sollen denn die kolleginnen und kollegen
gerade im niedriglohnbereich von 40 40
prozentigen lohnkürzung leben können und
beschäftigte in systemrelevanten gerufen
brauchen eine gefahrenzulage von 500
euro die bundesregierung hat jetzt
offensichtlich verstanden dass
verkäuferinnen und pflegekräfte
systemrelevant sind aber ein reines
dankeschön auch von der bundeskanzlerin
reicht nicht aus gerade gerade die
pflegekräfte in den krankenhäusern
leisten um über menschliches
übermenschlich ist und das mindeste was
die beschäftigte in diesen bereichen
verdient haben ist doch dass jetzt
endlich schluss ist mit dieser ganzen
profitlogik und deswegen ist auch nicht
nachzuvollziehen dass sie bei der
krankenhausfinanzierung wieder in das
gleiche fahrer im gleichen fahrwasser
verbleiben
wir erleben gerade in zeiten der krise
dass die menschen zusammenrücken dass
solidarität wächst das
nachbarschaftshilfe dass es
nachbarschaftshilfe gibt dass die leute
sich unterstützen und ich erwarte von
dieser bundesregierung dass die
solidarität für die menschen in diesem
land noch deutlich zunehmen vielen lang
will sich das ergebnis
der folge ermittelte ergebnis der
namentlichen abstimmung des
haushaltsausschusses zum antrag der
koalitionsfraktionen beschluss des
bundestags gemäß artikel 8 artikel 115
absatz 2 6 und 7 grundgesetz auf den
drucksachen 19 18 108 110 131 bekannt
abgegebenen stimmen karte 527 mit ja
haben gestimmt 469 mit einer gestimmt
drei enthaltungen 55 gemäß artikel 115
absatz 6 des grundgesetzes ist die
mehrheit der mitglieder des bundestags
erforderlich
das sind 350 jahre stimmen die
beschlussempfehlung ist mit der
erforderlichen mehrheit angenommen
next trainiert wird in der debatte zu
tagesordnungspunkt 6 ich die kollegin
kordula schulz-asche wirklich 90 die
grünen in diesen zeiten gibt es vieles
zu debattieren und zu beraten und
vorrangig aber und deswegen stehen wir
alle hier geht es darum um den schutz
der gesundheit um den schutz der
menschen hier in unserem land
in windeseile wurden gesetzes pakete
geschnürt um den bürgerinnen und bürgern
zu helfen und ihn auch die ausbreitung
des corona virus einzudämmen
und ich spreche hier sicher nicht nur
für mich wenn ich sage das
parlamentarische verfahren der letzten
tage die bemerkenswerte konstruktivität
dass die zusammenarbeit zwischen den
demokratischen fraktionen und der
regierung hier hervorragend funktioniert
hat und dafür möchte ich mich auch im
namen meiner fraktion bedanken
eine epidemische lage nationaler
tragweite gab es noch nie und es ist
richtig gesetzliche grundlagen zu
schaffen und zwar auf breit mit breiten
mehrheiten um die bevölkerung besser
beschützen zu können
dennoch dürfen solche tiefgreifenden
gesetze wie das infektionsschutzgesetz
nur zeitlich begrenzt sein und müssen
nach einer akuten situation auch
gründlich evaluiert werden
wir müssen in krisen für die zukunft
lernen und deswegen sind wir froh dass
unser forderung nach befristung dieses
gesetzes der gesetzlichen regelungen
tatsächlich nachgekommen wurde und sich
das jetzt im gesetz befindet dass es ein
wichtiges zeichen für die bürgerrechte
wir haben aber auch kritik was noch zu
tun ist
die beschäftigten im gesundheitswesen
den gilt gerade an unser aller größter
dank aber meine damen und herren worte
reichen nicht deshalb fordern wir weiter
einen einheitlichen zuschlag für
medizinisches und pflegerisches
fachpersonal der sie für ihre
tagtägliche harte und vor allem auch
gefährliche arbeit belohnt ich rede von
pflegekräften von ärztinnen und ärzten
medizinischem fachpersonal
aber ich möchte auch nicht die vielen
mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeiter den
öffentlichen gesundheitsdienste
vergessen die für den infektionsschutz
in unserem land zuständig sind bisher
nicht berücksichtigt sind auch
regelungen für andere berufe in den
gesundheitswesen die hebammen die
physiologen die physiotherapeutin
tschuldigung die logopäden um nur einige
beispiele zu nennen und wir gehen davon
aus dass ja auch wie schon angekündigt
im april wenn es noch weitere
nachbesserungen gibt dass wir diese
punkte genauer betrachten und auch noch
einmal verhandeln können und wir werden
auch sicher schauen müssen ob die
finanzielle unterstützung für die
krankenhäuser wie sie jetzt geplant ist
tatsächlich ausreichend ist meine damen
und herren in solchen situationen ist
solidarität angesagt solidarität heißt
dass wir auch die ärmsten nicht
vergessen dürfen familien mit kindern in
der grundsicherung oder solo
selbstständige wir müssen die ausnahme
im arbeitszeitgesetz befristen als wären
sie auch wir brauchen rettungsschirm für
die gesamte soziale infrastruktur damit
unser das soziale leben nicht
zusammenbricht ja solidarität ist
angesagt auf lokaler ebene um die
pandemie in den griff zu bekommen dort
wo infizierte menschen und erkrankte
hilfe brauchen wir werden die
zusammenarbeit von bund und ländern
verstärken müssen
um die epidemie in den griff zu bekommen
aber es ist auch eine globale krankheit
eine globale krise und deshalb ist auch
internationale sanität solidarität
gefragt in europa aber auch mit den
ländern der welt in der welt deren
gesundheitssysteme bei weitem schlechter
aufgestellt sind als die ur museum weil
damen und herren wir leben in einer zeit
in der es nicht um egoismus oder um
nationalismus geht sondern um
solidarität lokal bundesweit europäisch
und international ich danke ihnen für
ihre aufmerksamkeit
[Applaus]
karin maag cdu/csu drin
herr präsident liebe kolleginnen liebe
kollegen sowie ergebnis den dank gerne
zurück es war konstruktiv
ich will hier noch mal klarstellen wir
als gesetzgeber treffen heute im
bundestag mit der verabschiedung dieses
infektion dieses zusatz gesetzes zum
infektionsschutzgesetz die feststellung
dass es sich bei kiruna um eine epidemie
epidemische lage von nationaler
tragweite an diesen heutigen mit dieser
heutigen feststellung wird auch das bmg
der minister ermächtigt bundesweit
einheitlich weitreichende und zum teil
tief im private rechte eingreifende
anordnungen und rechtsverordnungen zu
erlassen
es geht vor allem um die grundversorgung
zum beispiel mit arzneimittel mit
labordiagnostik aber auch mit
persönlicher schutzausrüstung und ich
will hier schon betonen dass bereits
heute im gesundheitsministerium dazu
herausragendes geleistet wird
möglich werden aber auch zb
weitergehende verkaufsquote regelung zur
preisbildung und ähnliches und das ist
uns wichtig und es ist vor allem auch
rich
ich dass das gesundheitsministerium ist
spätestens 31 märz nächsten jahres einen
bericht zu den erkenntnissen aus der
korona epidemie vorlegen muss wo braucht
zb weitere personelle ressourcen bessere
gesetzliche regelung und so weiter und
mir ist auch wichtig dass wir hier im
bundestag den bürgern die gewähr dafür
bieten können dass mit solchen
weitreichenden befugnissen auch sorgsam
umgegangen wurde und ich bin mir sicher
jeder von uns hat bereits heute seine
persönliche to-do-liste im büro wo es
nachgearbeitet werden was muss anders
oder besser gemacht werden
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen die wohl
größte herausforderung in der nächsten
zeit steht und seinen krankenhäusern
bevor
zur sicherstellung der stationären
versorgung der patienten setzen unsere
krankenhäuser bereits seit dem 16 märz
planbare operationen aus tatsächlich
sind so schon 50 prozent der intensiv
kapazitäten frei geräumt worden
großartig aber auch allen anderen die
hier zusätzlich aufgaben übernehmen
niedergelassenen ärzte pflegekräfte die
reha einrichtungen die jetzt krankenhaus
aufgaben übernehmen und
kurzzeitpflegeplätze zur verfügung
stellen herzlichen dank ich bin ihnen
vor allem auch für sehr kreative
versorgungs ideen und die darum fußenden
anstrengungen dankbar und mit diesem
geld gesetz gleichen wir gleichermaßen
ein sonderopfer aus wir reagieren auf
dadurch verursachten einnahmeausfälle
wir stellen heute im rekord thema rund
zehn milliarden euro zur sicherung unter
anderem auch von liquidität zur
verfügung
und falls diese maßnahmen nicht
ausreichen jeder von uns hat in einer in
dieser woche hunderte von e mails dazu
erhalten dann steuern wir nach das bmg
kann
wird durch rechtsverordnung
entsprechende anpassungen auch vornehmen
jedenfalls die botschaft heißt wir sind
in der krise handlungsfähig herzlichen
dank was spd nicht so drin
[Applaus]
herr präsident
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen meine
damen und herren ich glaube niemand
haben die bilder aus italien spanien
oder anderen ländern kalt gelassen wenn
es darum geht zu sehen wie ein
gesundheitssystem zusammenbrechen kann
indem infektionszahlen sehr schnell
ansteigen und vor allen dingen
erkrankungen so massiv werden dass eine
gesundheitswesen überfordert ist
wir wollten vorbereitet sein deswegen
haben wir heute wirklich in einem
eilverfahren und ich bin allen dankbar
die daran mitgewirkt haben koalition
aber auch oppositionsfraktionen aber vor
allem den ministerien die daran an
diesem ganzen paket gearbeitet haben
nicht nur im gesundheitsbereich auch
dann dass der soziale schutzschirm von
hubertus heil
aber auch die bereiche aus dem aus dem
familienministerium bildungsministerium
alle haben dazu beigetragen aus diesem
paket jetzt ein weiteres ein breites
paket zu packen für die menschen die
jetzt vorbereitet sein müssen und im
gesundheitswesen haben wir in erster
linie jetzt erstmal die gebeten die
kliniken haben und die ärztinnen und
ärzte und die pflegefachkräfte sich
bereitzuhalten für einen tag iks der
hoffentlich nie auf uns zukommen wird
aber wir haben deshalb gesagt ms betten
frei halten und deshalb ist es unsere
aufgabe jetzt mit diesem paket was noch
nicht allumfassend ist aber mit diesem
paket deutlich zu finanzieren die
liquidität genau für diese bereiche für
die kliniken dass sie die betten eben
freihalten und vorbereitet sind und
deshalb sind die pauschalen die wir
jetzt auch zum ausbau der verdoppelung
der intensivbetten generieren jetzt auch
genau die richtigen maßnahmen
dennoch das ist gerade schon
angesprochen worden haben wir in den
letzten tagen stunden wochen von vielen
auch aus der gesundheitsbranche berichte
bekommen ich glaube das gilt für alle
abgeordneten hier im hause wo uns
menschen aus den wahlkreisen berichten
wie es ihnen gerade geht die
verunsicherung wie geht es weiter
was passiert mit meiner psychotherapie
was passiert auch mit denen die eine
praxis haben physiotherapie
heilmittelerbringer ich will ihnen
hiermit sagen diese mails sind nicht
ungehört bei uns angekommen und ich will
auch noch mal deutlich machen dieses
paket was wir jetzt verabschieden wird
nicht das letzte sein
wir dürfen nicht zu tun als wäre das
auch wenn es ein milliarden-paket jetzt
ist und eine kraftanstrengung wo wir
jetzt schon versuchen möglichst viele
bereiche abzudecken
dass wir noch mal deutlich machen damit
hört das nicht auf wir werden wir
arbeiten jetzt alle auch ich weiß das
aus den ministerien alle jetzt schon
daran welche bereiche müssen wir noch
stärken und ich will das auch in die
richtung des müttergenesungswerkes sagen
weil jetzt massiv die brief bekommen und
sie haben vollkommen recht wir müssen
auch diesen bereich stützen denn eins
ist ganz wichtig dass uns jetzt auf
dieser strecke nicht eine
versorgungsstruktur die wir bisher
hatten zusammenbricht wir brauchen sie
auch nicht nur jetzt sondern auch in der
zukunft und deshalb müssen wir auch
diese bereiche abdecken und stützen und
der minister hat mit heutigem tag eine
große möglichkeit bekommen auch
nachzusteuern über verordnungen und
rechtsverordnungen und ich würde mich
sehr freuen und ich unterstütze das auch
seitens der spd-fraktion wenn wir genau
die bereiche uns anschauen und auch
danach steuern denn es kann nicht sein
dass uns eine versorgungsstruktur am
ende weg bricht die bisher alle menschen
gut versorgt hat nur weil es an liquiden
mitteln gerade fehlt diese praxis und
vor allen dingen auch fachkompetenz und
diese menschen
existenz zu sichern darum bitte ich alle
und ich freue mich auch dass die
solidargemeinschaft das mitmacht die
zehn milliarden die gerade beschrieben
worden sind sind nicht nur bundesmittel
sondern sind auch mittel der
beitragszahler rinnen und beitragszahler
nämlich die gesetzlichen
krankenversicherung die das alles jetzt
auch auch viele verordnung schon spontan
und sehr flexibel umgesetzt und
verändert haben auch dafür herzlichen
dank dass das gelungen ist dass wir
dieses paket von rund zehn milliarden
gemeinsam tragen und hoffentlich noch
maßnahmen finden werden um alle anderen
abzudecken vielen dank und vielen dank
für die arbeit voraussichtlich letzte
regeln dieser debatte kollege peter weiß
cdu csu herr präsident verehrte
kolleginnen und kollegen die wir mit
bürgerinnen mitbürger zunehmende
individualisierung
ellenbogengesellschaft was ist nicht
schon alles um den zustand unserer
deutschen gesellschaft geschrieben
worden
ich finde wir zeigen zurzeit deutschland
seine mitbürgerinnen mitbürger können
auch anders nämlich zusammen stehen sich
solidarisch zeigen außergewöhnliches
leisten und ich finde das macht uns
stark in dieser krise und dafür möchte
ich alle mitbürgerin mitbürgern
absichern
und mit unseren gesetzen dem sozial
schutzpaket den gesundheits gesetzen
wollen wir diese stärke zusätzlich
unterstützen
ich darf hat den sozialschutz paket
einfach mal noch einmal die wichtigsten
daten nennen erstens wir stellen unsere
sozialen dienste und einrichtungen und
einen besonderen schutz
damit sie auch für die zukunft
leistungsfähig bleiben
zweitens wir machen zeitlich befristet
die regelungen um zb bei bezug von
kurzarbeit zusätzliche jobs möglich zu
machen
oder dass wir auch für diejenigen die
vorzeige ende gegangen sind einen
höheren zuverdienst möglich machen
oder dass wir die kurzfristige
beschäftigung von 70 auf 100 15 tage
erweitern und andererseits für alle die
wir gehen aus und wegfall ihrer
tätigkeit sich sorgen machen
zuallererst die neuen
kurzarbeiterregelungen und es sei daran
erinnert diese kurzarbeiterregelungen
haben uns schon mal in eine andersartige
andersartigen krise geholfen schnell
wieder raus und nach fördert zu kommen
aber eben genauso für alle die unter
einkommensverlusten jetzt leisten ein
schneller zugang ein einfacher zugang
zum arbeitslosengeld 2 gleiches gilt für
den kinderzuschlag auch die verordnungs
möglichkeiten für den
bundesarbeitsminister zum beispiel
flexibilität bei der arbeitszeit zu
zeigen wird uns helfen diese krise zu
meistern
meine sehr geehrten damen und herren in
vielen bereichen haben wir nicht wegfall
von arbeit sondern haben wir zusätzliche
anforderungen zum beispiel im bereich
von gesundheit und pflege
aber weil zum beispiel in wenigen tagen
in den gebieten mit sogenannten
sonderkulturen die andere zeit beginnt
in unserer landwirtschaft in der eben
nicht die große zahl von saisonkräften
aus anderen europäischen ländern zur
verfügung stehen
und genau so haben wir zusätzliche
arbeit anfalle das hat der
bundesarbeitsminister vorgetragen in
unseren shops ändern
arbeitsagenturen die schnelle eine große
flut von anträgen er bearbeiten und
erledigen müssen und deshalb muss unsere
hilfe die wir ermöglichen möglich machen
dass dieser ersatz oder zusatz bedarf an
arbeitskräften auch bereit gestellt
werden
meine sehr geehrten damen und herren ich
finde mit dem sozialschutz paket mit den
gesundheits gesetzen machen wir unser
sozialsystem unsere wirtschaft unsere
arbeit nach politik zusätzlich starb die
bürgerinnen bürger können sich darauf
verlassen dass ist eine wichtige
botschaft in dieser zeit der
verunsicherung und deshalb ein
herzliches dankeschön anerkennung für
das was aldi leisten die jetzt
zusätzlich gefordert sind im
gesundheitswesen in der pflege in
unserer verwaltung in unseren shops
ändern
sie helfen mit überstunden und der große
einsatz not zu lindern und dort wo
geholfen werden muss wie möglich zu
machen
vielen dank ich finde wir haben gutes
auf den weg gebracht wir sollten jetzt
engagiert unterstützt nur nutzen
dankeschön damit schließt sich die
aussprache zu tagesordnungspunkt 6 a
kommen wir zur abstimmung über den von
den koalitionsfraktionen eingebrachten
gesetzentwurf zum schutz der bevölkerung
bei einer epidemischen lage von
nationaler tragweite der ausschuss für
gesundheit empfiehlt unter nummer eins
seiner beschwerde auf drucksachen 1856
und 18 168 den gesetzentwurf der
fraktion der cdu/csu und spd auf der
drucksache 18 111 anzunehmen
hierzu liegt ein änderungsantrag der
fraktion die linke auf der drucksache
aktien 165 vor über den wir zuerst
abstimmen wer stimmt für diesen
änderungsantrag wer stimmt dagegen
enthält sich
dann ist dieser änderungsantrag gegen
die stimmen von fdp und die linke mit
den stimmen des übrigen hauses abgelehnt
jetzt bin ich diejenige die den
gesetzentwurf zustimmen wollen um das
handzeichen das stimmt dagegen enthält
sich dadurch der gesetzentwurf in
zweiter beratung bei enthaltung der
fraktionen von fdp und die linke mit den
stimmen des übrigen hauses angenommen
wir kommen zur dritten beratung und
schlussabstimmung und da bitte ich
diejenige die gesetzentwurf zustimmen
wollen sich zu erheben und wer stimmt
danke schön stimmt dagegen wäre enthält
sich daran gefährlich der gesetzentwurf
mit denselben mehrheitsverhältnissen wie
die zweite lesung angenommen jetzt
kommen wir zur abstimmung über den
entschließungsantrag der fraktionen die
linke auf der drucksache 18 166 wer
stimmt für diesen entschließungsantrag
wäre stimmt dagegen enthält sich dann
ist dieser entschließungsantrag bei
enthaltung der fraktion würde sollte die
grünen gegen die stimmen der linken mit
den stimmen des übrigen hauses abgelehnt
wir setzen sie die abstimmung für den
beschluss der beschlussempfehlung des
ausschusses für gesundheit auf der
drucksache 18 156 farb- und nummer zwei
seiner beschlussempfehlung empfiehlt der
ausschuss folgenden beschluss zu fassen
der deutsche bundestag stellt mit
inkrafttreten des paragrafen 5 absatz 1
satz 1 infektionsschutzgesetz aufgrund
der derzeitigen ausbreitung des neuen
corona corona virus saß tv2 in
deutschland eine epidemische lage von
nationaler tragweite fest wer stimmt für
diese beschlussempfehlung es gibt
dagegen wäre enthält sich dann ist diese
beschlussempfehlung bei enthaltung der
fraktionen von fdp die linke
mit den stimmen des übrigen hauses
angenommen damit kommen wir zu
tagesordnungspunkt 6 p abstimmung über
den von den fraktionen der cdu/csu und
spd eingebrachten gesetzentwurf zum
ausgleich cupid 19 bedingter finanzielle
belastung der krankenhaus und weitere
gesundheitseinrichtungen der aus ist ein
gesunder den vielen zeit haben sich auf
drucksache 18 151 8 10 163 den
gesetzentwurf der koalitionsfraktionen
auf der drucksache 18 112 unterausschuss
fassung anzunehmen wer stimmt für den
gesetzentwurf der ausschuss fasste die
um das hand sein
wer stimmt dagegen wer hält sich dann
ist der gesetzentwurf in zweiter
beratung bei enthaltung der fraktionen
der afg gegen die stimmen der linken
angenommen
wir kommen zu dritten beratung
schlussabstimmung da bietet ihnen die
dem gesetzentwurf zustimmen wollen sich
zu erheben dahin gesehen gegenstimmen
der angeführt enthaltungen
der gesetzentwurf ist mit gleiche
mehrheitsverhältnissen dritter lesung
angenommen wir kommen zur abstimmung
über den entschließungsantrag der
fraktionen die linke auf der drucksache
1867 wer ist im für diesen
entschließungsantrag
wer stimmt dagegen wer enthält sich dann
ist dieser entschließungsantrag bei
enthaltung von bündnis 90 die grünen
gegen die stimmen von fdp und die linke
mit den stimmen des übrigen hauses
abgelehnt zu tagesordnungspunkt 6 c
abstimmung über den von den
koalitionsfraktionen eingebrachten
gesetzentwurf für den erleichterten
zugang zu sozialer sicherheit sicherung
und zum einsatz und zur absicherung
sozialer dienstleistungen und aufgrund
des corona wie rosas tv2 sozialschutz
paket der austria arbeit und soziales im
winterschlussverkauf der drucksache 18
130 den gesetzentwurf der
koalitionsfraktionen auf der drucksache
1807 anzunehmen die fraktion die linke
hat beantragt über den gesetzentwurf
getrennt abzustimmen und zwar zum einen
fatih gelacht änderung des
arbeitszeitgesetzes und zum anderen über
den gesetzentwurf im übrigen also rufe
auf zunächst auf den artikel 8
ich bin diejenige die artikel 8 des
gesetzentwurfs zustimmen wollten das
anzeigen
wer stimmt dagegen wäre enthält sich
dann ist dieser antrag der artikel 8 ist
angenommen gegen bei enthaltung von
bündnis 90 die grünen gegen die stimmen
der fraktionen die linke nun rufe ich
auf die übrigen teil des gesetzentwurfs
und bittet diejenigen die zu stehen
wollen dass anzeigen gesetze nur für
übrigen so jetzt nochmal wer sind
dagegen
wer hält sich der gesetzentwurf ist in
zweiter lesung im übrigen die übrigen
teile einstimmig angenommen damals in
alle teil des gesetzentwurfs die zweite
beratung angenommen
wir kommen zur dritten beratung zur
abstimmung da bitte ich dir in die den
gesetzentwurf zustimmen wollen sich zu
erheben
daher gegenstimmen und enthaltungen
dann ist der gesetzentwurf ein dritter
beratung einstimmig angenommen er es
liegen drei entschließungsantrag der
fraktionen der afd sowie ein
entschließungsantrag der fraktionen die
linke form der stimme zunächst über den
entschließungsantrag der fraktionen der
af der drucksache 18 143 abwehr stimmt
dafür wäre stimmt dagegen
er enthält sich der antrag ist gegen die
stimme der afc mit den stimmen des
übrigen hauses abgelehnt jetzt kommen
wir zur abstimmung über den
entschließungsantrag der fraktionen der
afc auf der drucksache 18 144 wieder
stimmt dafür bestimmt dagegen wäre hält
sich auch dieser entschließungsantrag
ist gegen die stimmen der afg mit den
stimmen des übrigen hauses abgelehnt und
wir kommen zur abstimmung über den
entschließungsantrag der fdp fraktion
auf der drucksache 18 145 es gibt dafür
er schwebt dagegen wäre enthält sich
auch dieser entschließungsantrag ist
gegen die stimmen der afc mit den
stimmen des übrigen hauses abgelehnt und
damit kommen zur abstimmung über die
schließungs antrag der fraktion die
linke auf der drucksache 18 146 wer
stimmt für diesen antrag wäre es stimmt
dagegen wäre enthält sich eines dieser
entschließungsantrag bei enthaltung
verbunden sollen sie grünen gegen die
stimmen der linken abgelehnt damit
kommen wir zu tagesordnungspunkt 6 d
dass ich die abstimmung über den
gesetzentwurf der fraktion der afg zur
sicherstellung konsistenter maßnahmen
zum schutz der bevölkerung bei einer
bundesweiten gesundheitsgefahren einer
epidemie
der ausschuss für gesundheit empfiehlt
in seiner beschlussempfehlung auf den
drucksachen 1855 und 1864 den
gesetzentwurf der fraktion der afc auf
der drucksache 18 106 abzulehnen
ich bitte diejenigen die dem
gesetzentwurf zustimmen wollen um das
handzeichen
wir stehen über den gesetzentwurf haben
also die afg wer stimmte gegen er
enthält sich dann ist der gesetzentwurf
gegen die stimmen der afg mit den
stimmen des übrigen hauses abgelegt die
zweite beratung und nach der
geschäftsordnung entfällt die weitere
beratung tagesordnungspunkt 6 abstimmung
über den antrag der fraktion der effekt
der drucksache 1814 mit dem titel schul
und kita schließungen rechtssicherheit
für eltern und ihre kinder
wer stimmt für diesen antrag wer stimmt
dagegen wer enthält sich der anderer
gestiegen die stimme der afd
mit den stimmen des übrigen hauses
abgelehnt tagesordnungspunkt 6 f
abstimmung über den antrag der
fdp-fraktion auf der drucksache 18 113
mit dem titel lebensnotwendige logistik
erhalten lkw-fahrer und damit die
versorgung mit lebenswichtigen gütern
unterstützen bzw sicherstellt wer steht
dafür wer ist dagegen
er enthält sich der antrag ist gegen die
stimme der afg mit den stimmen des
übrigen haus abgelehnt
tagesordnungspunkt 6 g das ist der
antrag der fraktion der afc auf der
drucksache 18 118 mit dem titel sichere
eigenversorgung und mobilität
parkraumbewirtschaftung aussetzen
emissions- bedingte fahrverbotszonen
vorübergehend aufheben busspuren für pkw
freigeben wer stimmt für diesen antragen
wer stimmt dagegen
wer enthält sich der antrag ist gegen
die stimme der afg mit den stimmen des
übrigen hauses abgelehnt wenn sie wenn
sie mir weiterhin ihre aufmerksamkeit
schenken
wir sind beim tagesordnungspunkt 6 a und
stehen über den antrag der fraktion der
af der drucksache 1817 mit dem titel
sonderprogramm bus freiwilligendienst
mit familien und senioren bezug in das
bundesfreiwilligen die gesetz aufnehmen
wer steht dafür wer stimmt dagegen
wehren enthält sich auch dieser antrag
gegen die stimmen der afc mit den
stimmen des übrigen hauses abgelehnt
jetzt hoffe ich auf den
tagesordnungspunkt 7
sie dürfen alle dableiben
wenn sie wechseln halten sie abstand
da sich die beratung der
beschlussempfehlung des auswärtigen
ausschusses zu dem antrag der
bundesregierung zur ergänzung des
einsatzes bewaffneter deutscher
streitkräfte stabilisierung sicher und
wieder steigen des verhindern versöhnung
fördern in irak und syrien liegt dazu
ein entschließungsantrag der fraktion
die linke vor
für die aussprache eine dauer von 30
minuten beschlossen
und da wir alle heute